Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Chaos Radio im Blue Moon hier auf Fritz, was regelmäßig stattfindet. Alle zwei Monate kommen hier Leute vom Chaos Computer Club und Anverwandte und aus dem näheren Umfeld und erklären irgendetwas, was mit diesem seltsamen Internet zu tun hat, was wahrscheinlich nicht wieder weggehen wird. Und wir sprechen heute tatsächlich über ein Thema, das uns schon ein bisschen länger begleitet ist. Fast über ein Jahr her ziemlich genau, wo wir gesprochen haben, über was von Snowden übrig blieb, also über Bewachung im Internet, über einen NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss und darüber, was man mit Geheimdiensten eigentlich anstellen kann. Und das ist immer noch, muss man sagen, ein Thema, was sich geändert hat, was die Zukunft so bringt und was uns jetzt aktuell erwartet, das sprechen wir heute. Zum Beispiel mit Zebas vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mit Ulf Bohmeier, eigentlich Strafrecht am Landgericht, aber auch sehr umtriebig, ich sag's mal, in der Netzaktivisten-Szene. Hallo und guten Abend. Und hallo und guten Abend noch mal. Hallo. Ah, viel besser, meine Schuld, Entschuldigung. Und Katharina Nocun, ihres Zeichens Campaignerin. Und was das genau bedeutet und warum wir das brauchen, klären wir heute im Verlauf der Sendung auch noch. Hallo und guten Abend. So, wir haben vor einem Jahr hier geredet über den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Und das ist ja ein Thema, für das sich eine kleine Menge von Leuten sehr lange interessieren. Aber vielleicht gibt es auch vor der nurartigen Rundfunkumfangsgeräten immer noch Menschen, die gar nicht wissen, was das überhaupt ist. Möchte mal bitte jemand kurz erklären, was das ist, wozu es gut ist und warum wir es brauchen? Herr Zebas, Sie waren ja heute dort, hab ich mir sagen lassen.
Genau. Ich bin heute morgen um 11.30 Uhr in den Bundestag gegangen, um an der 112. Sitzung des ersten Untersuchungsausschusses in Bezug auf die NSA-Affäre teilzunehmen.
Und was ist dieser NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss?
Der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss wurde von den Parteien des Deutschen Bundestages eingesetzt, um entsprechend das, was von Snowden veröffentlicht worden ist, dort Licht ins Dunkle zu bringen und Klarheit zu schaffen, inwieweit deutsche Dienste da involviert sind, für die Five-Eyes-Staaten Ermittlungsarbeit zu leisten und in welchem Zusammenhang auch exterritoriale Tötungen, die durchgeführt worden sind, mit Hilfe der deutschen Bundesregierung geschehen sind.
Das muss man vielleicht schon mal ein kleines bisschen erklären. Bei exterritorialen Tötungen geht es um Drohnen, die mit Hilfe von Daten, also Mobilfunkdaten auch, Raketen abschießen. Und darum geht es darum, wie der BND da vielleicht beteiligt war oder nicht. Das erklären wir heute auch noch vielleicht ein bisschen genauer. Jetzt ist es ja so, also Snowden ist jetzt drei Jahre her. Dieser Untersuchungsausschuss, den gibt es jetzt wie lange? Auf jeden Fall über ein Jahr.
Seit 2014.
Seit 2014. Und wann immer man damit redet, wir erklären es auch noch genauer, ist das alles sehr schleppend und anstrengend. Und ich würde von euch gerne wissen, warum beschäftigt ihr euch überhaupt noch mit diesem Thema? Also warum stehst du heute irgendwie so, also seit 11.30 Uhr in diesem Ding und bist von dort quasi direkt ins Studio gekommen.
Genau, das ist halt ein Thema, was uns alle beschäftigen sollte und auch ein Stück weit dazu beiträgt, wie wir jetzt mitbekommen und warum wir heute Abend auch wieder hier sind, dass wir mitbekommen, wie Grundrechte verletzt werden, die für uns alle gut sind und dadurch halt auch Ermittlungen betrieben werden, welche Gesetzeslücken aktuell bestehen, die die Dienste ausnutzen. Und dort jetzt durchaus bevorstehende BND-Gesetz im Grunde genommen, eine rechtliche Klarheit geschaffen wird, dass der BND das, was er in der Vergangenheit illegal gemacht hat, jetzt offiziell tun darf. Und das Ganze auch noch ausgeweitet wird und dafür immer der Deckmantel des Terrors und des Schreckens genutzt wird, um die Sachen durchzudrücken. Und wenn wir uns anschauen, dass bis dato durch keinerlei Ermittlungsarbeiten, die die Dienste leisten, irgendein Terroranschlag verhindert werden konnte.
Warte, warte, warte. Du argumentierst jetzt schon inhaltlich. Was ich wissen wollte, ist, warum du dich, also du ganz persönlich als Person, die mit dem Thema überhaupt noch beschäftigst, wo das doch so zäh ist eigentlich.
Ich finde es halt wichtig, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und das nicht einfach so geschehen zu lassen und Leute darüber auch zu informieren, was dort passiert und darüber aufzuklären. Weil der Großteil der Bevölkerung sich einfach mit dem Thema nicht auseinandersetzt. Und es ist einfach verdammt wichtig, weil wir dadurch auch unsere Demokratie aufgeben, die wir in der Bundesrepublik haben und auf die wir stolz sein sollten und für die wir uns einsetzen sollten, dass die weiter bestehen bleibt.
Okay, warum das möglicherweise bedeutet, dass die Demokratie aufgegeben wird, obwohl auch der Geheimnis uns schützen soll, das klären wir vielleicht auch noch im späteren Fall der Sendung. Ulf, Herr Strafrichter ja eigentlich und es gibt ja im juristischen Bereich ganz viele Themen, mit denen man sich beschäftigen kann. Jetzt bist du netzaktivistisch im weitesten Sinne unterwegs. Warum? Also warum beschäftigst du dich auch noch mit diesem Thema, dem Geheimdienst-Thema, was mir frustrierend vorstelle?
Das hat einen persönlichen Hintergrund. Also ich habe mich sehr intensiv immer schon mit IT-Themen beschäftigt, seit ich irgendwie zum zehnten Geburtstag einen C64 bekam. Ich habe mein Studium weitgehend finanziert als Netzwerkadministrator an der Juristenfakultät in Leipzig. Das heißt also dieses Schnittgebiet Jura und IT ist schon Ewigkeiten mein Thema gewesen und so habe ich mich juristisch immer schon sehr intensiv beschäftigt mit der informationellen Selbstbestimmung, also dem Datenschutzgrundrecht oder auch mit Telekommunikationsfreiheiten und das sind genau die rechtlichen Fragen, die auch bei der Kontrolle von Geheimdiensten die zentrale Rolle spielen. Das heißt also das hat mit meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit ganz wenig zu tun, aber sehr viel mit meinen sonstigen juristischen Interessen und Schwerpunkten.
Und ich möchte das unterstellen, du hast Hoffnung, dass man dann noch was ändern kann.
Also grundsätzlich habe ich immer Hoffnung, dass man etwas verbessern kann, dass man was gestalten kann. Ich glaube einfach daran, dass man auch über die Art und Weise, wie Gesetze gestaltet werden, zum Beispiel Einfluss nehmen kann auf eine Gesellschaft. Allerdings ist der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss aus der demokratischen Perspektive, finde ich auch deswegen so spannend, weil er genau zeigt, dass es eben Behörden gibt, die die Rechtslage nicht immer und in jedem Einzelfall wirklich zur Leitschnur ihres Handelns machen. Da gibt es einfach Behörden, wo Menschen arbeiten, die sagen, okay, also wir versuchen uns ans Gesetz zu halten, aber wenn das mal nicht zu dem passt, was wir tun wollen, dann machen wir eben was anderes. Und das ist, finde ich, eine Verhaltensweise, die in einem Rechtsstaat nicht geht. Also beruflich als Strafrichter bin ich damit beschäftigt, solche Menschen zu verurteilen, wenn sie sich strafbar gemacht haben. Und das Interessante ist, dass der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss eben Beamten, Geheimdienstmitarbeitern auf der Spur ist, die sich zwar vielleicht nicht strafbar machen, die aber eben auch Gesetze übertreten. Und das, denke ich, geht einfach nicht. In einer Demokratie, das kann man nicht hinnehmen.
Also zwei Personen, beide haben gesagt, Demokratiegefahr. Katharina, wie ist es bei dir? Du bist ja Campaignerin, also quasi, das ist ja jemand, der dafür sorgen soll, dass Menschen für Themen auf die Straße gehen. Und jetzt habe ich also gerade, was diese, also überhaupt Netzaktivismus im Allgemeinen und Geheimdienstkontrolle, im Speziellen sind es ja eher Themen, die als trocken und da ist eigentlich nichts losverschrieben. Warum beschäftigt man sich nachhaltig mit so einem Thema?
Ja, ganz einfach. Ich bin in einem IT-Lahraushalt aufgewachsen. Das heißt, meine Mutter ist Datenbankadministratorin, mein Vater ist Programmierer und ich hatte immer einen Rechner und Internet und meine Eltern sind damals aus Polen nach Deutschland gekommen, auch weil sie gesagt haben, die politische Situation war damals in Polen nicht die Ideale. Also es gab Proteste, Kriegszustand. Wenn ich in der Uni demonstriert habe, haben meine Eltern immer gesagt, so ja, Kindergeburtstag bei uns standen sie mit Maschinengewehren vor der Uni und haben uns da rausgeholt. Und dann wird die Vorratsdaten Speicherung irgendwann eingeführt bzw. sollte eingeführt werden. Und ich habe das auf Heise gelesen damals und dachte so, what the fuck, das ist nicht euer Ernst. Ihr wollt nicht in einer Demokratie einführen, dass jede Kommunikation mit jedem, wann ich mit wem, von wo aus kommuniziere, für mehrere Jahre gespeichert wird. Und da habe ich gedacht, ich muss jetzt was unternehmen, ich muss jetzt was tun. Und seitdem engagiere ich mich in dem Bereich und ich sehe ganz konkret die Gefahr auch für die Demokratie. Denn in meiner Familie gab es auch Menschen, die wegen ihrer politischen Überzeugung ins KZ gekommen sind damals. Und gerade jetzt mit rechten Parteien auf dem Vormarsch in Europa sollten wir sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein, mit großen Datenspeicherung auch, was politische Überzeugung angeht. Und genau das machen ja auch Geheimdienste. Sie legen solche Datenbanken an. Genau das macht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und deshalb bin ich überzeugt davon, wir müssen etwas unternehmen, ansonsten geht die Demokratie den Bach runter. Da bleibt nichts mehr von über.
Harter Tobak. Und jetzt ist ja sozusagen das, was heute auch stattgefunden hat, dieser Untersuchungsausschuss. Was genau ist denn da im letzten Jahr passiert? Oder andersrum gefragt, ist im letzten Jahr überhaupt so viel passierend, dass man jetzt sagen kann, okay, das Ergebnis des Untersuchungsausschusses im letzten Jahren sind folgende Ergebnisse, die da zusammengetragen wurden?
Na, wir kriegen halt ein Stück weit Klarheit darüber, was bei den Diensten genau passiert. Die Abgeordneten sind leider mit der Mauer-Taktik der Bundesregierung konfrontiert, die die Aufklärungsarbeit natürlich nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen halt verhindert. Und wir werden erst sehen können im Februar nächsten Jahres, wenn es den Abschlussbericht geben wird, was halt in den nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen verhandelt ist. Das sind halt Sachen, die uns aktuell fehlen. Um überhaupt zu sehen, was alles wirklich im Argen bei den bei den Diensten liegt. Das fehlt halt aktuell ein Stück weit. Wir kriegen halt nur das mit und auch in der Medienberichterstattung, was in den öffentlichen Sitzungen besprochen wird, was die Sachverständigen dazu beitragen. Und der Teil der geheimen oder nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen fehlt halt ein Stück weit in der Berichterstattung. Und das wird es erst im nächsten Jahr, im Februar geben. Und dann kann man wirklich erst absehen, welche Konsequenzen das Ganze haben wird.
Also das hört sich ja an. Man kann noch gar nichts sagen.
Ja doch schon. Also man kriegt halt einiges an Klarheit schon, nur wirklich das vollumfängliche Ausmaß der Katastrophe überblicken zu können. Dafür fehlen halt die Sachen, die aktuell in nichtöffentlichen Sitzungen auch verhandelt werden oder besprochen werden.
Aber was kann man denn sagen?
Die Dienste verstoßen gegen jegliches Gesetz, was es gibt. Also sie halten sich an keine Vorgaben. Noch ein bisschen konkreter.
Also ich meine, du sagst nur, wenn man sich das mit dem Thema beschäftigt.
Sie agieren im Grunde genommen vogelfrei. Also sie ordnen oder setzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen ein, wofür sie keine Beschlussgrundlage haben, die sie sich dann im Nachhinein erst genehmigen lassen.
Noch mal die Frage, gibt es sowas Konkretes? Also kann man sich das so vorstellen, im Untersuchungsausschuss kommt dann raus, die haben an der und der Stelle das und das gemacht. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass diese und so weiter und so fort.
Genau, also ein aktuelles Beispiel ist, was man halt aktuell versucht, auch in den öffentlichen Sitzungen zu klären, inwieweit Mitarbeiter des BNDs dabei geholfen haben, Drohnentötungen im Ausland durchzuführen und welche Parameter durch die Dienste weitergegeben worden sind an Mitglieder der Five Eyes, um diese Tötung durchzuführen.
Und?
Das Ergebnis ist, ja, sie haben mitgeholfen, sie wollen es aber nicht zugeben. Die Fragen werden halt meistens damit beantwortet, dass die Zeugen sich nicht daran erinnern können.
Wow, gab es neulich auch noch so ein Gutachten, wo es darum ging, ob technisch überhaupt diese Daten, die da weitergegeben wurden, ausreichen? Genau.
Und diese Tote vorzunehmen? Wo will ich es da genau? In dem Gutachten wurde nochmal offiziell behandelt, dass es auch im Ausschuss nachgehalten ist und auch als Beweismittel verwendet werden kann, inwieweit man durch die Daten halt Leute wirklich ermitteln kann. Also inwieweit eine Ortung über halt die Mobilfunkrufnummer oder halt die E-Mail des Handys wirklich durchgeführt werden kann. Das ist bis jetzt ja immer von den Diensten geleugnet worden, dass das wirklich so genau möglich ist. Und jetzt gibt es halt nochmal ein offizielles Gutachten, auf das man sich berufen kann, dass das doch sehr genau möglich ist.
Und es ist sozusagen zweifelsfrei nachgewiesen, dass der BND diese, sozusagen so eine Mobilfunkdaten auch weitergeht und aufgrund dessen dann...
Genau, es ist ja auch schon nachgewiesen, dass Daten, die man erhoben hat, auch gefälscht oder verändert worden sind und dann weitergegeben worden sind.
Inwiefern?
Man hat halt ab einem gewissen Zeitpunkt gemerkt, wofür die Daten eingesetzt werden, die man an die anderen befreundeten Dienste weitergibt. Und da sind halt Tötungen mit durchgeführt worden und hat dann gesagt, man verändert die Daten oder gibt die Daten nicht mehr echtzeitgetreu weiter.
Die Tür öffnet sich und wir begrüßen noch einen weiteren Gast, auch ganz frisch aus dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Anne Roth, die sie jetzt ein Mikrofon teilen muss mit einem anderen Teilnehmer. Es ist ein Chaosradio, wir machen unserem Namen alle Ehre. Einfach sozusagen an eins der Mikros gehen und damit hineinsprechen. Ich habe gerade gesehen, da wurde heftigst der Kopf geschüttelt, dass irgendwie etwas mit den Drohensachen doch gar nicht so stimmen kann. Worum genau geht es, was ist schief gelaufen? Wie ist es wirklich? Einfach an eins mit dazustellen. Hallo, herzlich willkommen.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen zu spät, tut mir leid. Ich habe mich nicht von den letzten Zeugen losreißen können, der gerade im Moment noch im Ausschuss sitzt und Aussagt über die BND-Selektoren. Und weil aber noch zwei Kollegen von mir da geblieben sind, haben wir uns geeinigt, dass ich jetzt dann doch ganz schnell noch nach Potsdam fahre.
Okay, wir sprechen gleich noch genau darüber, warum du überhaupt da sitzt und das weiterverfolgst jetzt erst mal. Warum hast du gerade den Kopf geschüttelt, als es um die Drohnentötung ging?
Ich hab nicht ganz genau zugehört, aber ich glaube, ihr wart gerade dabei, was ist jetzt eigentlich nachgewiesen, was ist eigentlich schon rausgekommen und was macht der BND wirklich? Und genau was die Drohnentötung und die Übermittlung von Mobilfunkdaten angeht, sind wir im Moment im Grunde noch dabei, das nachzuweisen. Es ist so, dass einerseits sich relativ deutlich abzeichnet, dass Mobilfunkdaten weitergegeben worden sind. Wir hatten in der letzten Woche Zeugen aus der sogenannten HBW, der Hauptstelle für Befragungswesen. Das war eine BND-Abteilung, die nicht als BND gekennzeichnet war, die Flüchtlinge in Deutschland befragt hat seit kurz nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, zusammen mit einem amerikanischen Militärgeheimdienst und die dabei auch Mobilfunkdaten, also Telefonnummern zum Beispiel, abgefragt haben. Ganz vieles andere auch, aber eben auch das. Und auch die Amerikaner alleine teilweise mit diesen Flüchtlingen. Was wir nicht hieb- und stichfest nachweisen konnten bisher, ist, dass genau die Telefonnummern auch benutzt wurden, um dann damit Drohnen zur Ortung zu verhelfen, damit die dann Leute umgebracht haben. So ganz konkret ist es nicht.
Also ich möchte kurz versuchen, zusammenzufassen. Also es gibt den Nachweis, dass es eine Abteilung des BNDs gab, die mit Mobilfunkdaten gearbeitet hat und diese auch weitergegeben hat.
Es gibt den Nachweis, dass es die HBW gab, also diese Flüchtlingsbefragungsstelle. Das war schon ganz viele Jahre gab es das Gerücht. Zugegeben hat es die Bundesregierung tatsächlich erst vor anderthalb Jahren und hat dann kurz danach die HBW aber auch zugemacht und behauptet, das fände jetzt in dieser Form nicht mehr statt. Allgemeines sozusagen Befragen von Flüchtlingen über das Wissen über ihre Heimatländer. Und dabei sind auch Telefonnummern abgefragt worden.
Das Problem war ja, dass es quasi so eingebettete Befragende waren. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, beim Bundesamt für Immigration und Flüchtlinge. Das heißt also aus der Perspektive der Flüchtlinge entstand der Eindruck, sie kämpfen jetzt hier gerade um ihren rechtlichen Status, während sie in Wirklichkeit vernommen wurden.
Auch das nicht.
So habe ich das aus der Presse entnommen. Aber du weißt natürlich viel näher dran.
Also ich vermute, dass die meisten Flüchtlinge wussten, dass sie mit dem Geheimdienst sprechen. Der BND behauptet allerdings, dass sie sich immer nur vorgestellt haben, als Mitarbeiter der Bundesregierung, die im Interesse der Sicherheit Deutschlands gewissermaßen ganz freiwillig mit denen Gespräche führen und die natürlich auch ganz freilich aussagen können und das natürlich auch verneinen können. Interessanterweise sind das aber Flüchtlinge, die noch vor Anerkennung als Flüchtlinge ausgesagt haben. Und es würde mich jetzt sehr wundern, wenn sich das im Laufe der Jahrzehnte nicht rumgesprochen hätte, mit wem die da wirklich sprechen.
Okay, also es gibt das, also das Einsammeln von Mobilfunknummern, sagen wir mal, aus potenziellen Zielgebieten. Es gibt das technische Gutachten, dass tatsächlich eine Mobilfunknummer reicht, um eine Drohentötung durchzuführen.
Wenn ich da vielleicht noch einen Halbsatz anfügen darf, was ich wirklich irre finde eigentlich, ist, dass selbst zum Beispiel der Präsident des Verfassungsschutzes Maaßen in der öffentlichen Anhörung im Sommer noch im Ausschuss gesagt hat, ihm ist nicht bekannt, dass man mit Mobilfunkdaten tatsächlich Ortungen durchführen kann, wo gewissermaßen alle mit halbwegstechnischem Sachverstand außerhalb des Untersuchungsausschusses sich die Haare gerauft haben, gesagt haben, in welcher Welt lebt denn der. Aber das galt gewissermaßen als akzeptiertes Wissen in den Geheimdiensten, nach außen zumindest. Das geht nicht, das darf nicht gehen und deswegen ist das auch kein Problem, wenn wir Mobilfunknummern einsammeln, weil damit kann uns keiner vorwerfen, dass damit die Amerikaner jemanden umbringen, weil wir wissen ja nichts davon. Wir ignorieren einfach, dass es dieses durchaus nicht neue technische Wissen gibt.
Wobei man das nachlesen kann, nicht zuletzt in der Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts über den sogenannten IMSI-Catcher. Also das ist jetzt wahrlich kein Geheimwissen gewesen, der hätte einmal googeln gereicht.
Jetzt würde ich noch mal zurückkehren dazu, dass es ein Untersuchungsausschuss ist und würde fragen, es gibt also dieses Ding, dass man halt annimmt oder schon lange vermutet, dass da Mobilfunknummern genutzt werden, um Drohnentötungen durchzuführen und das ist jetzt sozusagen, das ist immer noch nicht endgültig rausgekommen, aber die Indizien verdichten sich. Wie lange hat das gebraucht um zu diesem Stand, also sagen von der Vermutung, die ja nach den Snowden Leagues irgendwann so relativ offensichtlich war, bis zu diesem Stand gekommen war und sagt, okay, jetzt fehlt noch der eine Schritt und dann haben wir es vielleicht?
Na das hat Sebastian gesagt. Wir sind im Grunde jetzt seit über zwei Jahren dabei, Zeugen zu vernehmen und haben in der letzten Woche tatsächlich diese konkreten Befrager der HBW vernommen, die dann auch eben ganz konkret bestätigt haben, dass Mobilfunknummern abgefragt worden sind. Das hat auch damit zu tun, dass wir ein halbes Jahr lang mit anderen Themen beschäftigt waren und uns jetzt nicht nur auf dieses Thema konzentriert haben, was mit Arthmetik von Fraktionen im Untersuchungsausschuss und Prioritäten und so weiter auch zu tun hat.
Da können wir jetzt vielleicht kurz einflechten, wer bist du überhaupt?
Guten Tag, wo bin ich?
Hallo, herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio, Anne Roth.
Genau, also ich bin Anne, ich arbeite als Referentin für die Fraktion Die Linke im Untersuchungsausschuss und mache damit sozusagen die Arbeit hinter den Kulissen mit den Referenten der anderen Fraktionen. Gemeinsam bereiten wir vor, was die Abgeordneten dann in dem Ausschuss tun, lesen die Akten, diskutieren, welche Zeugen gehört werden könnten, welche Themen in welcher Reihenfolge dran sind und bereiten dann auch die Fragen vor, die gestellt werden.
Und du bist von allen Anwesenden hier auch die Einzige, die auch in dem abgeschlossenen Teil, also dem nicht öffentlichen Teil des Untersuchungsausschusses sitzt, richtig? Aber darüber darfst du natürlich nicht reden?
Teilweise. Also ich kann, es gibt nicht öffentliche Beratungen der Abgeordneten, die sind nicht geheim, wobei auch die sozusagen aus Gründen nicht öffentlich sind und ich das jetzt hier nicht alles auf den Tisch packen werde. Und dann gibt es die sogenannten geheim oder vertraulich oder streng geheim eingestuften Sitzungen, wo es tatsächlich dann um sogenannte Staatsgeheimnisse geht. Und die darf ich eben hier nicht verraten.
Und jetzt hat aber Cebas gesagt, es wird irgendwann im Februar nächsten Jahres sozusagen ein Abschlussbericht geben und da werden auch die Erkenntnisse daraus in irgendeiner Form drin sein. Was genau, also wird das...
Leider nein, weil der geheime Bericht wird geheim eingestuft sein und außerdem den Abgeordneten darf den niemand lesen.
Inwiefern wird es dann sozusagen, also wird es dann aber Konsequenzen haben, nachvollziehbarer, oder werden wir nie wissen, was da passiert ist?
Na, es hat ja schon Konsequenzen. Da ist ein BND-Präsident entlassen worden. Der ist sicher nicht freiwillig gegangen. Und das ist, glaube ich, kein Zufall, dass der gegangen ist. Es wird ein neues BND-Gesetz geben, was die Koalition jetzt auch nicht einfach so aus Lust und Laune gemacht hat. Ich glaube, dass sich im BND eine ganze Menge getan hat. Es sind Leute versetzt worden und haben Disziplinarmaßnahmen gekriegt wegen Sachen, die rausgekommen sind. Und ich glaube, da tut sich eine Menge innerhalb des BNDs und innerhalb der deutschen Dienste, aber nicht alles davon ist öffentlich in der Form wahrnehmbar. Und ob das jetzt jenseits davon, ich sag jetzt mal im großen Wir, unserem Sinne tatsächlich dazu führt, dass weniger Überwachung stattfindet, das ist eine andere Frage, da bin ich skeptisch.
Nach der Nachrichten reden wir gleich über das neue BND-Gesetz, wollen mal gucken, wie weit wir dahin kommen. Du hast gerade gesagt, das hat jetzt zu lange gedauert, weil andere Themen, welche Themen gab es denn noch?
Ganz großes Thema im letzten halben Jahr waren die sogenannten Selektoren, also die Suchbegriffe, die eingesetzt werden, um die große Masse der erfassten Daten nach den Interessen sowohl der NSA als auch des BND zu durchsuchen. Und dabei kam ja relativ bald raus, dass da Selektoren dabei sind, die nicht dem entsprechen, was man sich so unter Aufgabe des BND vorstellt, also beispielsweise auch Personen oder Institutionen in Europa, in der EU, Politiker, dann aber auch zum Beispiel deutsche Firmen, die eigentlich nicht zum Aufklärungsziel des BND gehören sollten. Also da geht es dann um Wirtschaftsspionage.
Da muss ich kurz einhaken, weil letztes Jahr, als wir die Sendung hatten, da ging es darum, dass man gerne diese Selektoren wissen wollen würde, es aber sehr schwierig war, ranzukommen. Das heißt, da hat sich schon was getan noch.
Da hat sich eine ganze Menge getan tatsächlich. Also erst mal ging es nur um die NSA-Selektoren, und auch die wollte die Bundesregierung erst mal gar nicht zugeben, hat dann aber aufgrund der Arbeit des Ausschusses irgendwann öffentlich eingestanden. Das ist ein ziemliches Phänomen gewesen. Die Bundesregierung hat eine Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, in der explizit drinsteht. Wir haben da festgestellt, da hat es Sachen gegeben im BND, die waren nicht in Ordnung und die werden wir ändern. Das gibt es jetzt nicht alle Tage. Und die konkreten NSA-Selektoren, um die es da ging, die wollte sie dem Ausschuss nicht zeigen. Das hat dann lange gedauert und irgendwann kam dabei raus, es gibt nicht nur NSA-Selektoren, die schwierig sind, sondern auch BND-Selektoren, die schwierig sind. Dann haben wir gesagt, die wollen wir natürlich auch sehen, weil das ist ja auch alles erst rausgekommen, weil sich der Ausschuss damit beschäftigt. Zudem stecken die alle im selben Topf, in derselben Datenbank möglicherweise. Und das müssen wir uns natürlich deswegen auch angucken. Da hat die Koalition sich massiv gegengesperrt, also die SPD und Union auch im Ausschuss, im Parlament jetzt und die Regierung sowieso. Dann haben wir gesagt, wir erweitern den Untersuchungsauftrag. Da gehörte ursprünglich der BND nicht dazu. Eigentlich ist das Thema ja die Überwachung von GCHQ und NSA in Deutschland. Und das hat dann sehr viel Verhandelei und hunderttausende Sitzungen, von denen ihr nicht wissen wollt, wie schrecklich die waren, gebraucht, bis wir durchgesetzt haben, dass es das Recht der Minderheit im Parlament ist, zu sagen, wir brauchen die BND-Selektoren. Und irgendwann gab es die dann tatsächlich auch. Den Beschluss gab es irgendwann im Februar, März oder so. Und seit Sommer können sich Leute, die entsprechend hoch eingestuft sind, also entsprechend streng geheime Dokumente sehen dürfen, und die Abgeordneten tatsächlich sich die BND-Selektoren noch angucken. Und seit heute werden die dann tatsächlich im Untersuchungsausschuss auch mit Zeugen gesprochen.
Wow. Und aber im Februar nächsten Jahres ist dann alles vorbei? Oder ist das nur ein Meilenstein, das kann sein, danach wird noch weitergemacht?
Vorbei wird es sein, vermutlich im Sommer nächstes Jahr. Die Abschlussdebatte über den Bericht, den der Ausschuss schreibt, wird wahrscheinlich vor dem Sommer stattfinden. Uns wäre lieber danach, aber das sieht schlecht aus. Die öffentlichen Zeugenvernehmungen, die werden Februar, März vorbei sein. Und danach wird dann der Bericht geschrieben. Und dann wird, denke ich, Schluss sein. Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass wir momentan eine Situation haben, wo genügend öffentlicher Druck da ist, ein Parlament noch mal dazu zu bringen, so was zu behandeln. Leider, es ist viel offen. Da wird viel nicht fertig untersucht sein. Es müsste eigentlich noch sehr viel mehr gemacht werden. Aber das Parlament alleine wird sich da, glaube ich, nicht hinbewegen.
Fehlt öffentlicher Druck. Interessantes Thema. Darauf kommen wir auf jeden Fall noch zu sprechen. Und jetzt eine kleine Musik von Ain't No Love, Tears of Joy. Danach gibt es die Nachrichten. Danach geht es weiter hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon.
Für sein neues Album fängt er noch mal ganz neu an. Was für ein Zufall, dass es auch Neuanfang heißt. Und weil man neue Songs am liebsten zuerst mit alten Freunden teilt, kommt er zu Fritz und spielt sie euch vor. Fritz, die exklusive Pre-Listening-Session mit Clueso.
Oktober im Fräulein Fritz, dem Fritz Studio Kreuzberg.
Also, wenn ihr das neue Album von und mit Clueso hautnah und vor allen anderen hören wollt, dann einfach gut Fritz hören und klicken. Die exklusive Pre-Listening-Session von Clueso's neuem Album Neuanfang. Mit Clueso. Mit euch und natürlich mit...
Die Berliner SPD will mit Linken und Grünen über eine gemeinsame Koalition verhandeln. Der Landesvorstand sprach sich am Abend einstimmig dafür aus. In den Sondierungsgesprächen sei deutlich geworden, dass es bei wichtigen Themen viele Gemeinsamkeiten gebe, so Parteichef Müller. Mit einer Zustimmung wird auch in den beiden anderen Parteien gerechnet. Die Linke entscheidet morgen auf einem Parteitag, die Grünen treffen sich nächsten Mittwoch. An den Flughäfen Tegel und Schönefeld will das Sicherheitspersonal erst mal nicht streiken. Die Arbeitgeber und die Gewerkschaft Verdi haben sich im Tarifkonflikt um die rund 2500 Sicherheitsleute auf eine Übergangslösung geeinigt. Beide Seiten hätten einen Tarifvertrag bis zum Ende dieses Jahres geschlossen. Ziel sei es nun, einen längerfristigen Abschluss auszuhandeln, hieß es von Verdi. Bei dem schweren Zugunglück in den USA ist mindestens ein Mensch getötet worden. Vom Gouverneur des Bundesstaates New Jersey heißt es, mehr als 100 Menschen seien verletzt. Ein Penderzug war demnach ungebremst in einen Bahnhof in New Jersey, im Großraum New York gerast. Wie es dazu kam, ist noch unklar. Schalke 04 hat in der Europa League Österreichs Meister Erbi Salzburg mit 3 zu 1 besiegt. Damit hat Schalke den zweiten Sieg im zweiten Gruppenspiel eingefahren. In der Bundesliga hat Schalke noch keinen Punkt geholt. Fußball-Bundesligist Mainz 05 feierte seinen ersten Sieg in der Europa League. Die Mainzer gewannen in Baku beim FC Kebele mit 3 zu 2. Das Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Spandau 19 Grad und in Köpenick noch 22 Grad, in Prenzlau und Neuropin 20 Grad, in Brück 21 und in Cottbus 22 Grad. Am Abend und in der Nacht bleibt es bewölkt und zwischendurch kann es auch einzelne Schauer geben. Nachts kühlt es noch auf bis zu 12 Grad ab. Morgen bleibt es überwiegend grau und regnerisch, bei Höchstwerten um die 22 Grad. Vorsicht auf der A117-Zubringer Treptow. Zwischen Waltersdorf und Waltersdorfer Dreieck sind Leute auf der Standspur unterwegs. Statt Verkehr Berlin in Mitte ist die Strahlauer Straße wegen eines Wasserrohrbruchs gerade noch gesperrt. Zwischen Mühendamm und Janowitzbrücke in Richtung Holzmarktstraße. Zur S-Bahn auch heute Nacht ist die Strecke zwischen Friedrichstraße und Charlottenburg dicht. Zwischen Friedrichstraße und Zoologischer Garten fahren dann Busse im 20-Minuten-Takt. Und Probleme gibt es auch noch bei der U-Bahn Linie 7. Bis Ende November ist der Abschnitt zwischen Zwickauer Damm und Rudow unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahren dort Busse. Wo ihr durchkommt, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr Fritz bei Twitter, Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat oder YouTube folgen wollt, dann macht das doch, gebt da einfach Radio Fritz ein und da sind wir.
Heute Chaosradio in Blue Moon. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und zu Gast im Studio sind Cebas. Und Katharina Nocun. Und wir reden heute über Geheimdienste und ihre Auswirkungen auf unsere Gesellschaft, Gefahren für die Demokratie und was vielleicht in Zukunft werden kann. In der ersten halben Stunde haben wir darüber gesprochen, was der NSA und der Suchungsausschuss so treibt, dass das alles sehr lange dauert, dass es aber trotzdem erste Ergebnisse gibt und dass der im nächsten Jahr dann irgendwann vorbei ist. Und dann hat Anne Roth, die da auch arbeitet und bei jeder Sitzung zugegen ist, gesagt, naja, um das weiterzumachen, fehlt eigentlich der öffentliche Druck. Und ich würde tatsächlich gerne jetzt mal ein bisschen darüber reden. Ihr seid ja alle mehr oder weniger damit beschäftigt, dass dieses Thema auch an die Öffentlichkeit zu tragen, wie ihr das die vergangenen Jahre sozusagen erlebt habt. Ich würde gerne an einer Seite anfangen bei Cebas. Du setzt dich ja auch in diese Sitzungen, guckst du dir das quasi mit an? Und dann?
Genau, ich twitter während der Sitzung aus dem NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss, das was Zeugen sagen, wie sich die Leute von der Opposition und von den Regierungsparteien verhalten, auch welches Verhalten man von der Regierungsseite, also von den Vertretern der Bundesregierung und den Ministerien halt im Ausschluss mitbekommt und spreche halt auch mit Leuten im Freundes- und Kollegenkreis darüber, was man dort erlebt und was sich dort zuträgt.
Und ist das dann so, dass es über die Leute hinausgeht, die sich sowieso für das Thema interessieren?
Ja, definitiv, klar. Also wenn ich mir so angucke im Kollegenkreis, wer sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt, das sind eigentlich sehr wenige. Und im Freundeskreis haben auch schon viele Leute fast kapituliert, dass sich irgendetwas ändern wird.
Ulf, du bist ja sozusagen eine gewichtige Stimme, du bist ja mittlerweile gefragter Interviewpartner zum Thema auf, du machst Podcast Lage der Nation, du schreibst auch dazu. Was konkret von dem Thema trägst du in die Öffentlichkeit und wie sind die Reaktionen darauf?
Also ich habe jedenfalls den Eindruck, dass Überschreitungen des Rechts nach wie vor wahrgenommen werden. Ich glaube, es ist nach wie vor in der öffentlichen Diskussion ein Problem, wenn eine deutsche Behörde sich nicht ans Gesetz hält. Das ist so eine der ganz wenigen roten Linien, wo man zum Beispiel auch in der breiten Öffentlichkeit noch wahrgenommen wird. Oder eine zweite rote Linie scheint mir zu sein, wenn es einen Gesetzentwurf gibt, von dem man mit einiger Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen kann, dass er nicht mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbart ist. Auch das scheinen mir viele Journalistinnen und Journalisten zum Beispiel, aber auch viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger nach wie vor für ein Problem zu halten. Skeptischer bin ich bei der Frage, inwieweit Überwachung als solcher eigentlich ein Problem ist. Und das finde ich bei der ganzen Diskussion schon problematisch. Denn natürlich ist es, das habe ich ja eben auch eingangs schon gesagt, in einem Rechtsstaat nicht hinzunehmen, wenn Beamte, wenn Behörden Gesetze überschreiten. Auf der anderen Seite aber allein die Tatsache, dass irgendetwas in einem Gesetz steht, macht es aus meiner Sicht noch lange nicht legitim in einer Demokratie. Es macht es vielleicht legal, aber damit kann aus meiner Sicht jedenfalls die politischen Diskussionen auf gar keinen Fall beendet sein. Sondern die Frage muss dann sein, wie sollten denn eigentlich die Gesetze beschaffen sein? Was sollte denn eine Behörde dürfen? Wie gesagt, es ist ein Skandal, wenn eine Behörde ihre Vollmachten überschreitet. Aber nur wenn man ein Gesetz schreibt, das einer Behörde bestimmte Dinge erlaubt, ist das in einer Demokratie noch lange nicht wünschenswert, dass sie das auch tut.
Okay, zum Gesetz kommen wir tatsächlich später noch. Anna, wie ist es bei dir? Also du arbeitest ja für die Abgeordnete und bist du auch noch damit beschäftigt, das an die Öffentlichkeit zu tragen. Also du bist jetzt hier natürlich, aber ist das auch noch ein großer Teil deiner Arbeit?
Ja, eigentlich mache ich fast nichts anderes mehr. Nur übrigens, ich arbeite nicht für die Abgeordneten, sondern für die Fraktionen, was jetzt keinen großen Unterschied macht. Ja, doch klar. Also ich meine, ich habe ja diesen Job und wollte den auch gerne machen, weil ich mich mit dem Thema viel beschäftige, auch vorher schon und seit langem. Und mich vorher auch viel damit beschäftigt habe, wie man mehr dazu mobilisieren kann, dass da Protest wahrnehmbar wird. Oder auch mit der Frage, warum der langsam absinkt. Also das Bizarre in Deutschland vor allen Dingen ist ja, dass wir große Freiheitsstandangstbewegungen hatten und ungefähr mit Snowden ist das dann alles total in die Hose gegangen. Ja, das ist ja ein total irres Phänomen eigentlich. Mein Eindruck, also es gab häufig Leute, die erklärt haben, ja, es interessiert sich öffentlich niemand mehr dafür. Das ist ein Thema, das kann man nicht anfassen. Das berührt die Leute nicht. Wenn ich vergiss es, verkriegst du einfach keine Mobilisierung. Und mein Eindruck ist aber, wenn ich mit Leuten rede und wirklich ganz unterschiedlich, egal mit wem, irgendwie Eltern anderer Kinder an der Schule oder im Urlaub oder so, dass eigentlich allen seit Snowden viel bewusster ist, wie umfangreich Überwachung eigentlich ist und das in der großen Mehrzahl nicht gut finden und aber eigentlich resigniert haben, weil sie den Eindruck haben, man kann da einfach nichts dagegen machen. Die Regierung tut im Grunde so, als gäbe es kein Problem. Das ist ein internationales Problem. Was sollen wir da schon machen? Und dann noch die ganze Technik beherrscht sowieso kein Mensch. Also die meisten haben, glaube ich, einfach die Segel gestrichen und glauben nicht daran, dass sich da noch mal was ändern lässt. Und das finde ich ist ein Riesenproblem. Aber dass es niemand interessiert, das nehme ich überhaupt so nicht wahr.
Okay, also dann vielleicht, es ist in der Wahrnehmung, als ich auch von Ulf gerade gehört habe zu sagen, es gibt rote Linien, aber der Effekt bleibt vielleicht da außer. Katharina, du bist ja Campaignerin. Du hast eine Demo auch gerade angemeldet gehabt und durchgeführt. Was genau ist da passiert? Wie viele Leute waren da und war das ein zufriedenstellendes Ergebnis?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also erstmal, ich habe eine Petition gestartet in der Woche vor der Innenausschusssitzung gegen das BND-Gesetz und habe gesagt, liebe NGOs, jeder, der Bock hat, sich anzuschließen, kommt mit ins Bündnis quasi, schließt euch an, mobilisiert mit für das Event. Und dann haben wir innerhalb von einer Woche dafür mobilisiert und gesagt, wir machen jetzt hier eine frohe Testveranstaltung und ich würde sagen, also die Presseberichte waren deutlich geringer, also da stand irgendwie 40-50 Leute. Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, es waren deutlich mehr, es waren eher zwischen 50 und 100, weil viele haben sich dann so hingestellt, weil sie nicht auf die Fotos wollten, was bei einer Antiüberwachungsdemo auch, sage ich mal, ein natürlicher Effekt ist. Und für die Mobilisierung von einer Woche, finde ich, ist das schon ein guter Effekt. Und auch die Tatsache, dass man schnell und unkompliziert ein sehr breites Bündnis zusammenbekommen hat, von DigiGas über HU, über das FIF, Whistleblower-Netzberg.
HU ist aber nicht die Humboldt-Universität, oder was?
Die humanistische Union. Genau, Reporter ohne Grenzen war noch dabei, internationale Liga für Menschenrechte, die Cowridge Foundation hat noch zwei Whistleblower aus den USA mit eingeladen. Die waren da einmal Matthew Ho, der ein ehemaliger ranghoher US-Offizier ist, der seinen Dienst quittiert hat aufgrund der Drohnenmorde, die tatsächlich stattfinden nach wie vor. Und Cyan Westmoreland, ebenfalls ehemalig angestellt bei der US Army, der auch an irgendeinem Punkt dann die Meldung bekommen hat, du bist, du hast so und so viele Enemies quasi aus dem Weg geräumt. Dann hat er versucht, rauszufinden, wie viele Zivilisten denn dabei draufgegangen sind. Da hat er nie eine Antwort bekommen, dann auch seinen Dienst quittiert, weil er gesagt hat, er kann das moralisch nicht vertreten und hat noch mal auch ganz stark den Punkt gebracht auf der Demo. Liebe Leute, vielen Dank, das ist ein globaler Kampf, den wir hier führen. Ja und in den Jahren davor kann man ja sagen, bin ich quasi Dauergast gewesen vor dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Ich habe Proteste organisiert mit auch jeweils breiten Bündnissen, beispielsweise für ein Asyl für Edward Snowden in Deutschland, für eine Anhörung von Edward Snowden im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. Ich finde, es ist nach wie vor ein Skandal, dass der eigentliche Kronzeuge im Untersuchungsausschuss nicht aussagen darf. Und dagegen wird ja auch von der Opposition derzeit vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht geklagt. Und ja, dann haben wir demonstriert gegen die genannte Praxis, Dokumente großzügig zu schwärzen, die die NSA-Untersuchungsausschussmitglieder angefragt haben. Und ich finde, es ist ein Skandal, dass diejenigen, die den Geheimdienst kontrollieren, teilweise nicht die Akten bekommen, die die Zeugen vorher einsehen können. Und dagegen haben wir demonstriert. Wir haben gegen die Etat-Erhöhung demonstriert.
Wir müssen trotzdem mal zurückkommen zu den 100 Leuten. Weil egal, ob es jetzt 40 oder 100 waren, das ist ja beides trotzdem keine Masse.
Naja, montags um 12.30 Uhr müssen die meisten Leute eben auch arbeiten.
Ja, aber trotzdem sozusagen, das ist ja kein Aufschrei, sondern die Leute, die sich für das Thema interessieren. Für jedes Thema interessieren sich immer irgendwelche Leute. Aber das ist ja nichts, wo man sagen will, die breite Bevölkerung finde es wichtig genug, um da mal auch die Arbeit zu schwänzen und zu 10.000 auf die Straße zu gehen.
Na, das will ich erstmal nicht unterschreiben. Wenn beispielsweise die großen TTIP-Demos um montags um 12.30 Uhr gewesen wären und 90 Prozent aller NGOs, die in dem Bereich tätig sind, sich gesagt hätten, ja, es interessiert die Leute eh nicht. Die Leute Freihandelsabkommen, das ist total kompliziert. Da mobilisieren wir nicht zu, da machen wir keine großen Kampagnen. Da stecken wir nicht unsere Energie rein. Dann wäre das Thema in Deutschland auch nicht auf der Agenda. Und ich denke, da müssen sich die NGOs in Deutschland, die in dem Feld aktiv sind, auch klar machen, dass diese Mehr, und aus meiner Sicht ist es wirklich eine Mehr, dass Überwachung niemanden interessiert. Wirklich so nicht stimmt. Denn wir erleben es doch alle in unserem Umfeld und auch außerhalb des, sag ich mal, Nerd- und IT-Umfelds mit ganz normalen Leuten, mit unseren Großeltern, unseren Eltern. Die sagen alle, das ist eine Schweinerei. Und wenn jemand was organisiert, dann will ich sofort mitmachen. Das Problem ist nur, wir organisieren nichts.
Ich bin da ein bisschen skeptischer, ob wirklich so breite Kreise schon der Meinung sind, dass es sich um eine Schweinerei handelt. Denn um das so einschätzen zu können, muss man sich das ja doch schon sehr genau angeguckt haben. Zum Beispiel das BND-Gesetz, das geplante. Denn das ist ja doch einigermaßen komplex. Man muss sich da eben klarmachen, was denn eigentlich die Vollmachten sind, die dieser Geheimdienst bekommen. Also viele davon hat er sich früher schon genommen. Jetzt soll einiges davon legalisiert werden. Und auch noch einiges weitere. Das muss man sich erst mal klarmachen. Das ist eben nicht so ganz einfach. Also diesem Urteil, Schweinerei zu kommen, setzt einfach eine relativ intensive Beschäftigung voraus. Und dann, glaube ich, gibt es auch dieses kommunikative Problem, dass man ja, wenn ein Gesetz reformiert wird, wenn es eine Reform gibt, zunächst mal davon ausgeht, es wird alles besser, dass das neue BND-Gesetz im Wesentlichen eine Entgrenzung dieses Dienstes bedeutet, dass es kaum noch Grenzen dessen geben soll in Zukunft, was der Dienst alles abhören darf. Das nimmt man ja zunächst mal nicht an. Es gibt einen Skandal, die tun mehr, als sie dürfen. Dann denkt man ja, bei einer Reform wird das zusammengestaucht, was der Dienst tut, wird der Dienst quasi gleichsam wieder auf den Boden des Rechts zurückgeholt und dass man stattdessen das Recht derart entgrenzt. Das nimmt man ja intuitiv erst mal nicht an, wenn man von einer Reform hört.
Ein Spruch.
Ja, zweierlei Sachen. Einerseits wollte ich dazu was sagen, die NGOs, die da nicht zu mobilisieren, dem stimme ich zu. Ist aber auch so, dass die allermeisten NGOs, die wir haben, die sich im Bereich Grundrechte und Überwachung engagieren, würde ich wahrnehmen, ich weiß nicht, ob das ihre eigene Definition ist, aber die ich eher als Lobbyorganisation wahrnehme, die also sehr viel mehr Statements schreiben zu Gesetzentwürfen oder sich mit grundsätzlichen theoretischen Fragen ausnehmen, das trifft es jetzt nicht, das spitzt sehr stark zu, aber das sind keine Organisationen mehrheitlich, die sagen, wir versuchen Bewegung auf die Straße zu kriegen, wir versuchen Proteste zu organisieren. Und ich glaube, ganz viele Leute, gerade in der Zeit nach Snowden hatte ich den Eindruck, ganz viele Leute haben gesagt, wir wollen auf die Straße gehen, aber es gibt gar keine Demo. Das fehlte ein bisschen, dass die, die das in die Hand genommen haben, gesagt haben, so, wir organisieren jetzt hier den Protest. Da kann man wahrscheinlich auch lange drüber diskutieren. Dann würde ich total gerne noch was zu Ulf sagen, der sagt, das BND-Gesetz ist zu kompliziert.
Ich möchte, weil das jetzt schon häufig kommt, das BND-Gesetz machen wir noch ganz ausführlich in der nächsten halben Stunde. Wir machen es trotzdem, wir erklären es trotzdem ausführlich. Aber was ich jetzt wahrnehme, ist sozusagen, es gibt eine Art generelles Bedürfnis oder die Ansicht, Protest wäre notwendig, aber es hakt eigentlich an allen Ecken. Also es hakt sowohl bei den NGOs, wo man sagen würde, ok, eigentlich ist es eure Aufgabe, die Leute, von denen man annimmt, dass sie da sind, auf die Straße zu bringen. Andererseits auch, dass man sagt, also liebe Leute, ihr alle da draußen interessiert euch eigentlich nicht genug, vermuten wir zumindest. Jetzt hattest du schon einen Einspruch angemeldet.
Ja, also erstmal muss man sagen, fast jedes Thema, was wir im politischen Sektor von NGOs bearbeiten, ob es jetzt im Bereich Umweltschutz ist oder beispielsweise Handelsabkommen, das sind alles mega komplexe Themen. Nicht alle Leute, die jetzt vor einigen Wochen gegen TTIP und CETA auf die Straße gegangen sind, nicht viele davon haben den kompletten Vertragstext gelesen. So, ich hab tatsächlich große Teile des CETA-Abkommens gelesen. Ich finde es aber okay, wenn man sich drauf, also wenn man sich beispielsweise auch Berichterstattung verlässt und dazu sind Experten ja auch da. Experten sind dazu da, Dinge zu erklären und einfach runterzubrechen. Und ich persönlich weigere mich, die sogenannte BND-Reform zu nennen. Ich nenne sie BND-Gesetz, weil das ist auch ein Teil von politischer Kampagnenarbeit, Sachen so zu frameen, wie ich sie tatsächlich wahrnehme. Also beispielsweise, ich sage ja nicht Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung, ich sage Staatstrojaner, weil es genau das ist, was es ist. Und eine Reform ist aus meiner Sicht eben etwas, das wahrscheinlich etwas besser machen sollte.
Ich möchte wirklich nochmal bei den Leuten bleiben, die nicht auf die Straße gehen, in meiner Wahrnehmung. Und zwar jetzt hast du gesagt, naja, aber eigentlich irgendwie doch. Aber wo bleiben die denn?
Ja, also ich habe schon viele Großdemos mitorganisiert, also beispielsweise in Hamburg die großen Akta-Proteste, wo ich glaube 15.000 Leute am Ende da standen und wir alle dachten, wow, what the fuck ist hier passiert, richtig geil und man muss einfach sehen, viele Dinge, die von außen als Grassroots Bewegung daherkommen, wie beispielsweise die Akta-Proteste, waren tatsächlich in kleinen Städten oft von Einzelpersonen organisiert, aber in den großen Städten standen da immer Leute hinter, die öfter schon Dinge organisiert haben, die öfter schon Großdemos gemacht haben. Und man braucht einfach ein Netzwerk von organisierten Leuten, die sagen, wir trauen uns das zu, wir melden das an. Weil nicht jeder, der sagt, ich finde etwas schlimm, traut sich zu, beispielsweise eine Demo vom Reichstag anzumelden. Das klingt erst mal mega kompliziert.
Aber dann liegt es jetzt, ich sage das sozusagen allumfassend an euch, dass es nicht passiert, weil du sagst, man muss nicht immer alles durchsteigen, man kann sich auf die Experten verlassen. Und das ist ja tatsächlich so, wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, wenn man das auch nur quer...
Sonst könnten ja nur Juristen gegen Gesetze demonstrieren, das will ich ja nicht.
Es gibt ja genug Medienberichterstattung, die sagt, was da passiert, das ist zumindest komisch zu nennen. Also man muss nicht mal dagegen sein, was der BND macht, aber so, wie es gerade umgesetzt wurde, das geht auf jeden Fall eigentlich gar nicht. Aber trotzdem macht anscheinend trotzdem keiner. Also was mich interessieren würde, es gibt eine Theorie, warum zum Beispiel zu so einem, also auch ähnlich komplexen Thema, wie ein internationaler Handelsvertrag Leute auf die Straße bringt, vierstellig und fünfstellig, aber eine Komplettüberwachung, eine illegale Komplettüberwachung nicht?
Also das sind unterschiedliche Punkte und das ist eine sehr komplexe Gemengelage und ich habe mir dafür, darüber sehr viele Gedanken gemacht in den letzten Jahren und tatsächlich, also ich habe ja auch Einblick in andere NGO-Strukturen als Campaigner. Man redet ja beispielsweise auch mit Leuten von Greenpeace und so weiter und so fort und das ist einfach auch so, dass wenn man große, erfolgreiche Protestbewegungen sich anguckt, muss man erst mal sagen, die sind älter. Wenn ich mir die ganze Umweltbewegung anschaue, das sind einfach gewachsene Strukturen, das sind große Verbände, die über die Jahre gewachsen sind, wo man einfach auch sagen muss, die haben auch Ressourcen. Das heißt, wenn ich mir jetzt ein paar Vereiner angucke, die wirklich, wirklich gute Arbeit machen im netzpolitischen Bereich, die haben manchmal nur drei, vier Mitarbeiter, weil sie sich nicht mehr leisten können und dann haben sie eben oft die Situation, dass sie sich entscheiden müssen. Machen wir eine Großdemonstration und binden unsere drei Leute da dran oder versuchen wir Änderungsanträge, Lobbygespräche zu den fünf Gesetzen, die jetzt gerade durchkommen, zu machen. Und dann fällt die Wahl meistens auf Letzteres. Und ein zweiter Punkt ist, dass aus meiner Sicht das Thema Überwachung vollkommen, also oft falsch kommuniziert wird. Also wenn wir drüber nachdenken, was Überwachung denn eigentlich bedeutet, lohnt es sich aus meiner Sicht wirklich diesen großen Bogen der Demokratiegefährdung zu spannen und zu sagen, wir sind alle davon betroffen. Es geht eben nicht darum, Terroristen zu fangen. Es geht eben nicht darum, Kriminelle zu finden, sondern der Kollateralschaden, der dabei entsteht, greift das Fundament unserer Gesellschaft an. Und wenn man wirklich über diesen Punkt geht, haben wir viel mehr Betroffene. Und das ist tatsächlich auch aus meiner Sicht der Fall. Und dann kann man auch breitere Bündnisse schmieden.
Aber das ist immer die Frage, wie kriegt man das hin? Weil es gibt ja bei den transnationalen Handelsabkommen immer so schöne Bilder, auf denen man es runterbrechen kann. Das Chlorhühnchen war ja zum Beispiel so was. Aber was ist das Chlorhühnchen der Überwachung?
Das Chlorhühnchen der Überwachung? Na ja, das Chlorhühnchen haben wir nicht. Aber ich würde schon sagen, dass wir sehr starke Symbole oder auch Figuren haben, die Leute mitziehen, die Leute kennen, die einen sehr hohen Bekanntheitsgrad haben. Wenn wir allein mal an Edward Snowden denken. Edward Snowden ist jemand, mit dem können die meisten Menschen in diesem Land oder auch mittlerweile weltweit was anfangen. Und der steht für etwas. Und der steht für viele Menschen eben für eine sehr bewundernswerte Entscheidung und für eine Wende, auf die sie gehofft haben. Und ich finde es auch großartig, dass sie weiterhin politisch tätig sind. Und ich finde es auch richtig und wichtig, solche Figuren nach vorne zu stellen und zu sagen, wir stehen gemeinsam eben für etwas an. Also dieses Thema statt Köpfe. Und finde ich, ist da ein verkehrter Ansatz. Ich finde es total toll, sagen Helden der Bewegung aufzubauen und auch zu sagen, die können Fehler haben, die können Fehlentscheidungen in ihrem Leben getätigt haben, wie beispielsweise überhaupt bei der NSA anzufangen, klar. Aber dass sie ausgepackt haben, war doch eine coole Sache. Das einzig Wichtige.
Also es fehlt schon noch ein bisschen an der Figur, die das übernimmt, oder an Figurennen. Und es fehlt tatsächlich auch ein bisschen an Ressourcen einfach, damit man quasi das anschrecken kann. Anna hatte gerade aufgezeigt beim Chlorhühnchenüberwachung, dann hat sie erledigt.
Nee, ich finde, das ist eigentlich mit Snowden ganz gut erklärt.
Okay, so, falls ihr übrigens gerade vor euren neuen alten Grundfunk umfangs gerät und denkt, aber ich würde zur Demo gehen, und zwar aus folgendem Grund, oder ich würde auch eine organisieren, wenn ich nur wüsste, wie das geht, oder ihr denkt, ich würde auch nicht gehen, selbst wenn ihr das nicht mit organisiert, könnt ihr gerne anrufen, unter 0331 70 97 110. Ansonsten würde ich sagen, hören wir jetzt eine kurze Musik und dann geht es endlich zu dem lange erwarteten und schon oft angekündigten BND Gesetz. Chaos Radio in Blue Moon, mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Wir sprechen heute hier über Geheimdienste und wie man sie möglicherweise kontrollieren kann und zu Gast sind vom Chaos Computer Club. Sebas, hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Dann Ulf Bohmeier, hallo und guten Abend. Anne Roth. Und Katharina Nocun. Hallo. Hallo. Und wir haben schon besprochen, was eigentlich der NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss ist, inwieweit er mit dem BND zusammenhängt und warum eigentlich so wenig Leute auf die Straße gehen, wenn es darum geht, gegen Überwachung oder gegen illegales Vorgängnis BND zu protestieren und was man vielleicht machen könnte, um das zu ändern. Dann habe ich auch aufgerufen, dass ihr anrufen könnt, falls ihr zu einer Demonstration gehen würdet oder nicht. Und das hat der Micha jetzt tatsächlich gemacht. Aus Potsdam, hallo und guten Abend. Und du würdest, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe, nicht zur Demo gehen.
Weil, weiß ich nicht, man hat in seinem Leben so viele andere Dinge zu tun. Ich glaube, man hat selten Zeit und bei mir fängt der Schutz gegen den BND eigentlich ein bisschen zu Hause an. Indem ich mich natürlich versuche, meine Daten von mir und von meinem persönlichen Umfeld minimal zu halten. Ja, also ich glaube, es hilft schon, weil ich habe kein Facebook. Ich versuche eigentlich alle Dinge, die ich so betreibe, mal schön getrennt zu halten. Also ich kann jetzt nur von Mitteln reden. Man kann sich auf jeder Plattform mit seinem Facebook anmelden. Man kann sich auf jeder Plattform mit seinem Google Account anmelden. Muss man doch nicht. Man kann sich doch so viele schöne Trash-E-Mails anlegen. Also für jede Dienstleistung, die ich habe, habe ich einen anderen Zugang. Und damit ist es schon mal erheblich schwerer, alle Daten zu fusionieren und mitzubekommen.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, inwieweit du das treibst, aber insofern du nicht für jeden Dienst einen eigenen Rechner benutzt oder zumindest eine eigene virtuelle Maschine auf dem Rechner, halte ich es für relativ wahrscheinlich, dass ein Geheimdienst trotzdem mehr Daten sammeln kann.
Ja natürlich, das ist es.
Ich glaube, die Schwelle...
Aber der eigentliche Punkt ist ja, wenn du dich da vor dem Geheimdienst schützen willst, heißt das ja, du gehst davon aus, dass er doch was macht, was er eigentlich nicht machen soll.
Das wird er tun, ja. Aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist ja eigentlich die Paradoxie, wenn ich einen Geheimdienst haben möchte, der das Gesetz auf einer gewissen Art und Weise effektiv schützen kann, muss er ja auch in einigen Bereichen neben dem Gesetz oder über dem Gesetz stehen.
Warum?
Ja, weil es schwer ist.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, aber als Argumentation erscheint mir das ein bisschen dünn. Also warum genau, glaubst du, muss der Geheimdienst über dem Gesetz stehen? Also über dem Gesetz ist ja schon eine Formulierung.
Oder sagen wir neben dem Gesetz, oder er muss Befugnisse haben, die die Regelungen des Gesetze oder anders, er hat Befugnisse auch Regeln der Gesetze außer Kraft zu setzen. Interessant ist ja nur einfach interessant, wenn er jetzt Daten sammelt und sammelt und sammelt von mir persönlich. So, der interessante Aspekt kommt dann, was passiert wirklich mit den Daten? Und da muss die Kontrolle hin sein. Sag ich mal, jetzt, er hat jetzt zufällig nebenher herausgefunden, keine Ahnung, weil ich, weiß ich nicht, also man kann nicht mit dem Internet der Dinge...
Micha? Ich würde die Frage gerne mal weitergeben wollen, an die hier anwesenden Studiogäste. Da sagt also jemand, also Geheimdienst kann nicht funktionieren, wenn er nicht neben dem Gesetz steht. Hier haben wir einen Juristen. Was sagt der denn dazu? Also tatsächlich sozusagen, man kann das erst mal als Vermutung anschauen. Geheimdienst macht geheime Dinge, das irgendwie zu regulieren ist vielleicht schwierig. Geht es überhaupt? Also als Konzept kannst du Geheimdienst geben, der juristisch reglementiert ist oder gesetzlich reglementiert ist?
Da bin ich jedenfalls skeptisch, denn jedenfalls gibt es bislang kein Beispiel, wo das funktioniert. Jedenfalls nicht in der Bundesrepublik und für andere Länder will ich da jetzt lieber nicht sprechen. Ich finde aber die These interessant, die der Hörer gerade gemacht hat, Herr Micha, dass ein Geheimdienst über dem Gesetz stehen müsse. Denn ich glaube, das zeigt sehr schön, wie weit wir schon gekommen sind, nicht? Dass also die ständigen Rechtsbrüche durch Geheimdienste, soweit sie der NSI-Untersuchungsausschuss aufgedeckt hat, dazu führen, dass Bürgerinnen und Bürger jetzt quasi schon die Waffen strecken und sagen, ja das muss halt wohl so sein. Also ich finde das ehrlich gesagt schockierend und das ist jedenfalls eine Auffassung, die mit dem Grundgesetz nicht vereinbar ist. Das Grundgesetz geht ganz klar davon aus, dass kein Geheimdienst und auch sonst keine Behörde irgendetwas tun darf, wofür es keine gesetzliche Ermächtigung gibt. Das ist ziemlich einfach, jedenfalls soweit sie dann in Grundrechte eingreift und so ziemlich alles, was eine Behörde tut, greift in irgendeiner Art und Weise in Grundrechte ein, besonders natürlich ein Geheimdienst, einfach weil der ja Informationen sammelt. Das heißt also, sobald es irgendwie um personenbezogene Daten geht, greift er damit in jedenfalls in das Datenschutzgrundrecht ein.
So Micha, es geht also nicht. Hättest du jetzt lieber einen Geheimdienst, oder würdest du das Grundgesetz außer Kraft setzen, oder ändert das vielleicht deine Meinung?
Schwierig. Das Schwierige an einem Geheimdienst ist, wenn er Daten sammelt, hat er sie erst mal gesammelt. Wenn diese Daten, die er von mir persönlich sammelt, bis zu meinem Lebensende in einem dunklen Staufach sind und eigentlich nie irgendeine Relevanz weiter besitzen, dann ist das für mich persönlich in meinem Leben nicht so schlimm.
Naja, aber es wird immer jemanden treffen. Also die Frage ist, mit der Bitte um eine kurze Antwort, hältst du es für sinnvoll, einen Geheimdienst zu haben, der sich über die Gesetze hinweg setzt? Ist erstaunlich, finde ich auch so zu sagen. Das ist auch etwas, was ich vorhin meinte. Man redet ganz viel darüber und es scheint, zumindest in gewissen Kreisen, total einsichtig, dass das eigentlich keine gute Idee ist, aber anscheinend ist der Glaube daran, dass ein Geheimdienst was Sinnvolles anrichtet, ist anscheinend irgendwie da.
Naja, und es kam ja auch das klassische Argument, ich hab ja nichts zu verbergen so ein bisschen. Also bei mir wäre es nicht so schlimm, wenn die Daten nur sicher verstaut wären.
Aber das ist schon ein Schritt weiter, als ich hab nichts zu verbergen. Das ist schon eine Ansage. Ja klar, klar, aber es steckt mir drin.
Also ich hab den Hörer nicht so verstanden, dass er sagt, er findet es grundsätzlich gut, dass es Geheimdienste gäbe. Er sagt nur, auch seiner Meinung kann ein Geheimdienst nicht funktionieren, ohne dass der sich über bestimmte Spielregeln hinweg setzt. Und das finde ich ist der spannende Punkt, weil da quasi von dem gegenwärtigen Sein, wo es an dem es so viel Kritik gibt, quasi auf das Rollen geschlossen wird. Also nur weil es heute so läuft, es angeblich immer so sein muss. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist eine schwierige Aufgabe, aber nein, das kann noch lange nicht bedeuten, dass wir aufgeben können, Behörden ans Gesetz zu binden. Denn dann muss man sagen, dann haben wir wirklich so was wie einen Staat im Staat. Unser Parlament und damit letztlich die Bürgerinnen und Bürger steuern über Gesetze. Das ist die Art und Weise, wie wir versuchen, unsere Behörden irgendwie im Griff zu halten und dazu zu bringen, dass sie das tun, was eben die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung will. Und wenn wir diesen Anspruch aufgeben, dass sich Behörden ans Gesetz halten, das ist im Grunde wirklich Anarchie.
So und jetzt soll es tatsächlich so ein Gesetz geben, ein BND-Gesetz. Und bevor wir sagen, dazu kommt was drin, möchte ich mal eigentlich wissen, wo das herkommt. Also wir hatten jetzt neulich gerade diesen Effekt, dass irgendwie so Katastrophenschutzregeln verkündet wurden, wo man irgendwie sich so und so viele Packungen Milch in die Vorratskammer stellen wollte und haben alle gehofft. Und nein, das hat bestimmt mit dem Terror zu tun, aber einfach nur so eine turnusmäßige Aufarbeitung von Katastrophenschutzrichtlinien. Ist es, dass wir ein BND-Gesetz kriegen, auch sozusagen ganz normal und es trifft nur chronologisch zusammen? Oder ist das ein direktes Ergebnis von diesem Untersuchungsausschuss?
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein direktes Ergebnis vom Untersuchungsausschuss. Das letzte BND-Gesetz, das weiß jetzt vielleicht Ulf, das weiß ich gar nicht, aber das ist so richtig steinalt. Und ein paar andere Gesetze, die für die Geheimdienste gelten, also zum Beispiel das G10-Gesetz, was die Kommunikation und die Privatsphäre schützt, ist auch schon ziemlich alt, seit es das letzte Mal reformiert wurde. Es gibt, glaube ich, verschiedene Gründe, warum es das gibt, aber einer ist, würde ich sagen, auf jeden Fall, dass im Untersuchungsausschuss rausgekommen ist, dass der BND sich im Grunde seine Gesetze selber gemacht hat. Also da gibt es ein paar uralte Gesetze, die überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Stand der Technik sind, die also beispielsweise sowas wie auch technisch regeln, wie Kommunikationen und Telefonate überwacht werden, und die schlichtweg nicht mehr anwendbar sind, seit Kommunikation digital funktioniert. Ich versuche mal ganz kurz zu machen, nur als ein Beispiel steht in dem G10-Gesetz drin, dass bei bestimmten Formen von Überwachung nur 20 Prozent des Inhaltes eines Kabels, durch das Kommunikation läuft, erfasst werden dürfen. Dieses Gesetz wurde gemacht, als wir noch analog telefoniert haben und man damit 20 Prozent der Telefonate erwischt hat, seit Telefonie auf Internet umgestellt wurde und dann nur noch Pakete durchgehen, macht das keinen Sinn. Weil wenn du 20 Prozent der Pakete hast, hast du hinterher keine vollständige E-Mail, kein vollständiges Telefonat. Und statt dass der BND jetzt irgendwann, als das passiert ist und das war so 2004, 2005 in Deutschland gegangen ist und gesagt hat, das funktioniert so nicht, wir können mit dem Gesetz nicht arbeiten, weil die Technik hat sich weiterentwickelt, hat der BND gesagt, das funktioniert so nicht. Ach, dann machen wir das jetzt einfach anders, weil geht ja nicht. Und haben aber auch niemandem was davon gesagt. Ja, das wusste also auch die aufsichtführende Behörde in dem Fall, das Kanzleramt nicht. Und das ist ein gewissermaßen ein Beispiel von ganz vielen, was der Ausschuss gezeigt hat, dass der BND einfach komplett unkontrolliert macht, was er will, wenn man so will. Und das hat dann, glaube ich, auch die Bundesregierung irgendwann nicht mehr so richtig cool gefunden. Das Gesetz, was wir jetzt haben, müsste eigentlich noch abwarten, bis der Untersuchungsausschuss fertig ist und die Ergebnisse auch tatsächlich da sind. Das ist was, was wir kritisieren, dass die jetzt einfach alleine dahergehen und ein Gesetz machen, was faktisch legalisiert, was jetzt festgestellt wurde, was ja nicht richtig ist, was die machen. Also ich halte das für völlig falsch zu sagen. Das, was die machen, braucht jetzt einfach nur eine gesetzliche Grundlage und dann ist es wieder okay, sondern es müsste eigentlich eingeschränkt werden. Das ist aber, das hat mit Politik zu tun, natürlich unsere große Koalition, die den Geheimdienst aber auch gar nicht wirklich zügeln möchte. Und damit würde ich jetzt mal an die Inhalte dieses Gewinns.
Genau, das klang ja schon so ein bisschen an, dass es der Tenor, wann immer man auf dieses Gesetz trifft, das gesagt wird, na ja, das macht eigentlich nichts, außer alles legalisieren, was jetzt so gerade rauskommt. Kann man es ein bisschen genauer sagen, was da inhaltlich drinsteht oder drinstehen soll, muss man der Zeitung noch sagen?
Der Schwerpunkt dieser geplanten Reform sind Regelungen zur sogenannten Ausland-Fernmeldeaufklärung. Das klingt alles ganz furchtbar kompliziert. Es geht einfach darum, dass Telekommunikation, also z.B. Internetverbindungen im Ausland, abgehört werden, mitgeschnitten werden können durch den BND. Darum geht es. Und wann der BND das können soll oder dürfen soll, steht in diesem Gesetz drin. Und die Regelung ist relativ einfach, die da in Aussicht genommen wird. Der BND soll schlicht und ergreifend alle Netze abhören dürfen, die das Bundeskanzleramt bestimmt hat. Mit anderen Worten, das Bundeskanzleramt sagt, am DECIX in Frankfurt bitte mal mitschneiden und dann darf der BND eben den kompletten Internetverkehr, der durch den DECIX läuft, mitschneiden.
Entschuldigung, jetzt bin ich schon verwirrt, weil gerade ging es doch um Ausland-Ausland-Überwachung. Der DECIX steht in Frankfurt, wenn ich richtig informiert bin, was ja nicht ausland ist. Wie passt das zusammen?
Ja, das wäre insofern ein relativ schlechtes Beispiel, könnte man denken, aber es geht eben um die Telekommunikation, wo die Telekommunikation hinfließt, wo die dann tatsächlich abgegriffen wird, ist erst die zweite Frage, wenn tatsächlich die Telekommunikation von Ausländern im Ausland erfolgt, dann kann der BND damit schneiden. Und da ist eben die Frage, ob der DECIX da reinfällt oder nicht, da streiten sich gerade die Experten darüber. Denn wenn tatsächlich zwei Leute im Ausland kommunizieren und die Leitung aber dummerweise auch über Frankfurt läuft, könnte man auf den Gedanken kommen. Das ist eine der vielen, vielen Unschärfen des Gesetzes. Aber halten wir uns an diesem Beispiel vielleicht nicht zu sehr auf.
Ich möchte nur kurz eine kleine Technik-Erklärung. D-Kix ist, glaube ich, der größte Internet-Knoten sogar. Das Internet kann man sich vorstellen wie eine Ansammlung von Leitungen, die sich auch bündeln zu einem Backbone im Rückgrat des Internets. Das ist sozusagen in Frankfurt. Da gab es auch jetzt eine Klage, glaube ich, dass der Betreiber des G-Kix irgendwie gegen den BND geklagt hat.
Genau, der D-Kix hat 2009 eine Anordnung vom BND bekommen, dass die dort gerne abschnuscheln möchten. Das passiert auch. Und dagegen hat der D-Kix jetzt geklagt. Und das ist auch einer der Punkte des BND-Gesetzes, dass der BND ist im Grunde genommen der Auslandsnachrichtendienst der Bundesregierung Deutschland und der jetzt auch im Inland ermitteln soll. Es soll also mit dem Gesetz auch dazu ermächtigt werden, innerhalb von Deutschland die Kommunikation zu überwachen und auszuwerten.
Aber ich denke nur, um ausländisch zu kommunizieren, da habe ich es schon wieder erst bis jetzt verstanden.
Wobei, man kann ja auch gar nicht so klar differenzieren, ist das jetzt jemand, der kein deutscher Rechts-Träger ist, Grundrechts-Träger ist oder jemand, der sich im Ausland befindet. Wenn ich eine ausländische IP nehme.
Genau, wir haben bei den IP-Paketen einfach das Problem, dass vorne nicht dransteht, wo die herkommen. Also aus welchem Land die IP-Pakete stehen. Die haben jetzt vorne kein header dran, wo dran steht plus für neun, dass man Deutschland zuordnen kann.
Ja, ich finde, wir müssen, bevor wir in solche Details abgleiten, DECICS oder nicht DECICS, deutsche IP, nicht deutsche IP, müssen wir uns zunächst mal klarmachen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Denn das, glaube ich, wird noch nicht in der öffentlichen Diskussion genügend berücksichtigt. Es geht einfach darum, dass ein Schwingerzeig des Bundeskanzleramts reichen soll, damit der BND jede Leitung auf diesem Planeten anzapfen kann, solange darüber nur irgendein Ausländer aus dem Ausland kommuniziert. Und das ist in heutiger Zeit, wo man einfach nicht weiß, wie zum Beispiel IP-Pakete gerautet werden, jede Leitung. Das muss man so deutlich sagen. Der BND soll, wenn es nur das Bundeskanzleramt für richtig hält, jede Leitung abhören können. Und das ist einfach eine sehr, sehr weitreichende Ermächtigung.
Aber ist das schon so auch als Kritik herangetragen worden, einen Gesetzgeber, und gibt es auch eine Erwiderung zu?
Ich wollte gerade zu dem, was Ulf eben gesagt hat, vielleicht noch hinzufügen. Wir hatten eine Anhörung der linken Fraktion, und es hat dann danach noch eine Anhörung im Innenausschuss gegeben. Und bei der einen hat Klaus Landefeld, einer der Betreiber des D-Kicks tatsächlich, die diese Klage jetzt auch sagen, angestrengt, aber eine von diversen Klagen im Übrigen, die es gerade gibt, der hat zu diesem neuen Gesetz gesagt, das fasst das super zusammen, der NSA würde sich freuen, wenn er so ein Gesetz hätte, weil das so weit geht.
Deshalb hatten wir auf unseren Plakaten auch Nein zu deutschen NSA stehen.
Und an diese grundsätzliche Erkenntnis, dass das eine nahezu grenzenlose Lauscherlaubnis ist, die in diesem Gesetz steht, an diese Grunderkenntnis, dann schließen sich Detailprobleme an.
Aber noch mal die Frage, die gerade untergegangen ist, ist das an Kritik schon getragen worden, an den Gesetzgeber? Wenn ihr das da reinschreibt, dann hat das zur Folge, dass jede Leitung davon betroffen ist. Und was ist die Reaktion?
Es gibt Massenhaftkritik und es gibt wirklich schwergewichtige Kritik. Das finde ich wirklich phänomenal an dieser Situation, die wir gerade haben. Also es gibt ein neues Gesetz, was unglaublich weitreichend Überwachungsbefugnisse enthält. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel den ehemaligen Verfassungsrichter Papier, der ganz klar sagt, das geht so nicht, das kann man nicht machen. Der Wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages hat gesagt, das ist verfassungswidrig, das kann man so nicht machen. Es hat eine Reihe von, also die Anhörung im Innenausschuss, wo Sachverständige benannt werden von allen Fraktionen im Bundestag. Da haben auch bis auf einen, also alle gesagt, ihr organisiert euch eure Verfassungsklage mit dem Ding selber. Das geht alles überhaupt nicht, also nicht, also sehr viel differenziert, pro und contra und so weiter. Aber im Grunde alle, die gesagt haben, also aus verschiedensten Gründen ist das mit unserer Verfassung nicht vereinbar, was ihr davor habt. Und die Bundesregierung, also die ja auch schon vor drei Jahren übrigens als auch Verfassungsrechter in unserem Untersuchungsausschuss gesagt haben, hier bestimmte Sachen, die ihr dafür grundsätzlich geltend annehmt, nämlich zum Beispiel, dass ihr Ausländer einfach so überwachen dürft und dass für die der G10-Schutz, also Schutz der Kommunikation nicht gilt, das ist auch schon verfassungswidrig. Und dann sagt die Bundesregierung, das sehen wir anders. Das interessiert uns nicht. Also ich war gestern bei einer Veranstaltung, wo der Geheimdienstkoordinator Fritsche auch noch mal zum BND-Gesetz befragt worden ist und genau dazu auch noch mal gelöchert worden ist. Und dann setzt er sich dahin und dann lächelt er und sagt, naja, Sie wissen ja, die Bundesregierung sieht das anders.
Also das ist jetzt der Moment, wo ich persönlich sozusagen wieder ein bisschen resigniert bin. Also weil ich finde schon, man kann sozusagen so was diskutieren. Man kann auch aneinander sein und einfach sagen, es interessiert uns nicht. Das finde ich schon eine harte Nummer in der Demokratie. Aber gut, Ulf, du wolltest noch sagen, es gibt das große Problem. Dann gibt es noch viele kleine Probleme oder kleinere, die davon abgehen.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur auf deinen Einwand zurückkommen, dass es doch jedenfalls nach der Überschrift im Ausland Telekommunikationsüberwachung gehen soll und da gibt es auch bestimmte Regelungen, die zum Beispiel dazu führen sollen, dass Menschen aus europäischen Ländern etwas besser geschützt sind und die sollen auch dazu führen, diese Regelungen, dass Deutsche eigentlich gar nicht in diese Überwachung rein geraten können. Aber dazu hat Sebas ja gerade schon so ein paar Stichworte geliefert. Diese Filtersysteme arbeiten automatisch, das heißt also sie gehen nach ganz formalen Kriterien vor. Wenn ich mit einer Telefonnummer aus Deutschland telefoniere, dann habe ich vielleicht, oder im Ausland aber mit einer deutschen Handynummer zum Beispiel, dann habe ich vielleicht das Glück, dass dann klar ist, okay die Nummer fängt mit plus 4 9 an der deutschen Landeskennung. Mit etwas Glück wird sie dann eben ausgefiltert. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel als Deutscher im Ausland, wo ich normalerweise genauso geschützt wäre, mit einer amerikanischen Handynummer telefoniere, dann erkennen die Computer schon nicht mehr, oh la la, der ist ja Deutscher und schon funktionieren diese Filtersysteme nicht. Und selbst wenn man die irgendwie durch technische Fortentwicklung auf eine sehr hohe Genauigkeit, meinetwegen auch 99, 9 Prozent Treffgenauigkeit bringen würde, dann würde natürlich bei Milliarden von abgehörten Verbindungen immer noch jeden Tag eine Vielzahl von Verbindungen abgehört, die eigentlich nicht abgehört werden darf. Und das ist genau das Problem bei diesem Gesetz. Es ist eine uferlose Überwachung, die dem BND erlaubt wird. Und die Filterverfahren, das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel gewesen, diese Filterverfahren oder die sonstigen Grenzen, die in diesem Gesetz formal drinstehen, die erstmal den Eindruck erwecken, als wenn sie die Überwachungstätigkeit einschränken, die sind alle Gummiparagrafen. Das heißt, da gibt es überhaupt keine Begrenzung, die tatsächlich wirksam sind. Es gibt auch keine parlamentarische Kontrolle zum Beispiel. Da wird ein neues Geheimgremium geschaffen, in Karlsruhe angesiedelt, beim Bundesgerichtshof, wo zwei Bundesrichter und ein Mitarbeiter des Generalbundesanwalts sitzen und die dann im Nachhinein informiert werden, müssen nur welche Netze abgehört werden, nicht welche Suchbegriffe verwendet werden, nicht welche Personen gegebenenfalls. Das ist also ein Gesetz, das quasi auf der Stirn trägt. Wir wollen, dass der BND so gut wie alles darf und wir haben dann einfach nur so ein wenig rechtsstaatlichen Zuckerguss darüber gegossen. Und das ist wirklich in dieser Maßlosigkeit aus meiner Sicht beispiellos.
Sie sehen mich ein bisschen fassungslos. Ich will noch kurz nachfragen, geht es im Gesetz wirklich nur darum, also quasi um die Abhörung dieser Kommunikation? Also weil diese ganze Nummer mit den Drohnen kommt ja dann da gar nicht vor.
Na es gibt natürlich Regelungen zum Austausch mit anderen Staaten, auch die sind extrem weit gefasst. Also da gibt es dann zwar, ich will das jetzt mal kurz zusammenfassen, da gibt es dann die Voraussetzung, dass man sich auf so eine Art Spielregeln einigen muss. Man kann also jetzt nicht völlig frei Daten an einen ausländischen Dienst liefern, sondern man muss mit dem gewissen Terms bestimmte Spielregeln vorher aushandeln. Aber auch das sind alles Regelungen, die letzten Endes keine ernsthafte Begrenzung darstellen. Das ist sehr interessant, wenn man da mal ein bisschen in die Details schaut, dann sieht man immer, das ist geschrieben mit dem Anspruch im Kopf, dass alles gehen muss. Es muss sich so lesen, als wäre es eine rechtsstaatliche Kontrolle in Wirklichkeit, aber muss alles möglich sein. Und das finde ich wie gesagt aus der rechtsstaatlichen demokratischen Perspektive hochgradig problematisch. Darüber, finde ich, müsste auch viel mehr gesprochen werden. Wollen wir eine Behörde, die so gut wie alles darf, wenn es um Telekommunikationsüberwachung geht?
Die große Überraschung bei der Sitzung im Innenausschuss war ja, dass ausgerechnet der Ex-Chef des BND auch gesagt hat, dass die Beschneidung parlamentarischer Kontrollbefugnisse wirklich ein Fehler ist. Und ja, wenn wir uns noch mal das große Bild angucken, dass hier jetzt offensichtlich ein verfassungswidriges Gesetz durchgebracht werden soll, dann sehen wir, dass es in ganz vielen Bereichen im Bereich Überwachung immer wieder gemacht wird. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht wirklich ein Skandal, dass man sich als Bundesregierung hinstellt und genau weiß, das Bundesverfassungsgericht wird dieses Gesetz beschneiden, zurechtstutzen und dann gucken wir mal, was die Maximalversion ist, was wir da durchkriegen. Und aus meiner Sicht ist es wirklich, also wie kann man sich als Politiker hinstellen, als Justizminister beispielsweise und sagen, ich verantworte ein Gesetz, von dem ich schon weiß, dass es vom Verfassungsgericht zurückgepfiffen wird. Und da kann ich noch mal daran erinnern, dass diese These, dass Leute sich nicht für Überwachung interessieren, aus meiner Sicht nicht stimmt. Denn eine der größten Massenverfassungsbeschwerden in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik Deutschland war die Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Naja, aber die ist halt auch schon wieder eine ganze Weile her und seitdem hat sich viel getan.
Es gibt ja eine zweite.
Zu der man sozusagen, zu der man, aber naja, aber halt nicht mehr in dieser Masse halt.
Doch es gab eine Massenverfassungsbeschwerde von Digitalcourage und anderen Unterstützern, die auch 10.000 Unterstützer hatte.
Naja, aber sozusagen jetzt gibt es halt das BND-Gesetz und da schreit halt noch keiner und das ist halt schon, das finde ich schon bedenklich.
Genau, ich glaube, bis es dann zu einer Verfassungsklage kommt, das wird ja noch ziemlich lange dauern und bis dahin ist der Frost schon ganz schön weichgekocht, würde ich sagen. Also dann läuft dieses Gesetz schon eine ganze Weile und dann ist es glaube ich schwer, das nochmal wieder auf Null zurückzudrehen, selbst wenn sich die politische Situation dahin wandeln würde. Weswegen ich mich gerade nochmal gemeldet habe, war, ich habe auch erst gestutzt, als Schindler in der Innenausschussanhörung gesagt hat, also dass selbst er findet, dass da mehr parlamentarische Kontrolle hin muss, als im Gesetz steht. Ja, klar, aber Schindler ist auch als BND-Präsident abgesetzt worden und der findet, dass das Kanzleramt ihn als Bauernopfer genommen hat dafür, dass sie selber sich aus der Verantwortung gestohlen haben, weil das Kanzleramt nämlich gar nicht wissen wollte, was der BND eigentlich macht und der findet und das hat auch Fritzsche gestern Abend nochmal gesagt, das BND-Gesetz, das wird gemacht für die BND-Mitarbeiter, um die besser zu schützen, damit die nicht den Ärger abkriegen, wenn irgendwann rauskommt, was die alles machen, wenn das vorher schon bekannt ist, dann ist das Kanzleramt und die Bundesregierung schuld, aber nicht der BND und das möchte der ehemalige BND-Präsident gerne.
Ist das eine gute Idee? Also ich meine, da könnte man jetzt auch sagen, okay, so kann man es vielleicht wirklich machen. Der Geheimdienst zu sagen, macht erst mal, aber die schuld muss dann die Politik tragen.
Ich persönlich finde beides nicht richtig, weil ich gerne nicht möchte, dass die das machen und dass die nicht so eine Überwachungsbefugnisse haben, aus genau den Gründen, die Ulf ja schon genannt hat. Je schlimmer die Überwachungsgesellschaft ist, die du hast, und das haben wir ja jetzt schon, die Chilling-Effekte sind enorm. Also die wahrgenommene, irgendwie in allen Geräten steckende Dauerüberwachung, die wir haben, die führt dazu, dass Menschen sich im Grunde nicht mehr trauen, irgendwo aufzuschreiben oder irgendwo auszusprechen, was sie wirklich denken. Und damit ist die Meinungsfreiheit massiv angegriffen. Wenn du permanent das Gefühl hast, du wirst beobachtet irgendwie und du weißt gar nicht woher, dann überlegst du dir ganz genau, wie und wo und was du äußerst. Und diesen Freiraum, den wir aber als Grundlage von Meinungsfreiheit brauchen, der ist, finde ich, dessen Einschränkung ist das tatsächliche Problem, warum wir so ein BND-Gesetz nicht haben dürfen.
Und die technische Hürde, sich vor Überwachung zu schützen, wird ja konstant, die Latte wird immer konstant wieder eine Latte höher gelegt. Also wenn ich mich an unseren Anrufer eben erinnere, ich finde es ja grundsätzlich gut, wenn man sich Gedanken macht, aber ich denke dann immer so, naja, was wird meine Oma machen? Die ist jetzt keine IT-Expertin gewesen. Und selbst wenn ich verschlüssele heute, ist ja die Frage, wird irgendwann ein Gesetz durchkommen, was Verschlüsselung in Deutschland rechtlich verbietet, dass ich mich strafbar mache, wenn ich Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen nutze, ohne Bektor. Und diese Diskussion poppt ja immer wieder alle paar Jahre auf. Und wenn wir jetzt konstant, sag ich mal, der Frosch im Wasser ist und das Wasser erwärmt sich und wir gewöhnen uns langsam daran, dann macht es mir wirklich Sorge, dass so etwas irgendwann durchkommt. Und dann haben wir alle die Konsequenzen. Selbst wenn ich sage, ich hab nichts zu verbergen und ich werde nicht in den Radar eines BND oder eines Verfassungsschutzes oder der NSA geraten, meine Daten werden erst mal trotzdem abgegriffen. Und naja, ich lese ja Zeitungen als normaler Bürger. Ich nehme ja an der Politik in diesem Land teil. Und wenn ich keine Journalisten mehr habe, die frei berichten können, frei recherchieren können, wenn ich keine Politiker mehr habe, die frei agieren können, keine Aktivisten, die Protest organisieren, dann ist mein, also dann leben wir in einer verzerrten Demokratie, die aus meiner Sicht auch keine Demokratie mehr ist.
Gerade auf dieses letzte Stichwort Journalisten, die überwacht werden, wollte ich noch ganz kurz eingehen, einfach weil ich da ein konkretes Beispiel dazu bringen kann. Ich kenne ja ganz gut Markus Becke, Andre Meister, die den meisten Hörern wahrscheinlich noch bekannt sind, spätestens seit der Netzpolitik-Affäre im vergangenen Sommer. Und als diese Ermittlungen liefen, wo der Generalbundesanwalt Ermittlungen geführt hat wegen des Verdachts des Landesverrats. Da haben die sich natürlich große Gedanken gemacht, ob sie jetzt überwacht werden. Und ich habe da so einen gewissen Eindruck bekommen, was das eigentlich bedeutet, als Journalist zu arbeiten in der Befürchtung, dass da jetzt gerade irgendeinen Geheimdienst oder irgendeine Strafverfolgungsbehörde in der Leitung hängt bei jedem Telefongespräch. Oder dass die eben auch an der Internetleitung hängen. Das ist einfach eine extrem schwierige Arbeit, weil man eben selbst, wenn man sich mit Technik gut auskennt, wie eben Markus und Andre, eben extrem konzentriert vorgehen muss, um sich da überhaupt noch schützen zu können und vor allem auch um Quellen schützen zu können. Und ich denke, wir alle wissen, dass Journalistinnen und Journalisten ihre Arbeit einfach nicht tun können, ohne Informationen. Das heißt, sie sind darauf angewiesen, dass Menschen wissen, dass sie sich sicher fühlen können, wenn sie sich an Journalisten wenden. Und das sichere Wissen ist einfach nicht mehr da, wenn zum Beispiel eben der BND im Prinzip jedes Byte, das durch das Internet fließt, erst mal mitschneidet. Wie gesagt, es gibt da bestimmte Filterregeln. Sie können jetzt nicht alles 100 Prozent auf ihre Festplatte legen, aber wer weiß denn schon, welche Suchbegriffe die jetzt verwenden.
Und trotzdem ist es so, es gibt immer noch das Argument, dass gesagt wird, ja, aber die Überwachung, also ich hab jetzt gerade ein konkretes Beispiel bekommen für eine Berufsgruppe, wo das natürlich relevant ist. Aber es gibt immer noch heute die sagen, na ja, aber man merkt es halt selber nicht. Robert ist einer von denen jetzt am Telefon. Hallo, guten Abend.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend. Grüß Gott.
Du sagst, man merkt Überwachung nicht und deswegen wehrt sich keiner.
Genau, Überwachung ist total subtil. Im Endeffekt kannst du nichts sehen. Du würdest die Überwachung vielleicht wahrnehmen, wenn deine Daten irgendwo draußen wieder auftauchen. Das ist aber nicht der Fall. Insofern wirst du dich auch nicht gegen Überwachung wehren, weil du sie eben nicht bemerkst.
Aber das widerspricht genau dem, was hier gerade gesagt wurde. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo tatsächlich selber davon ausgehen muss, dass du überwacht wirst, dass es halt doch dann einen Effekt hat.
Genau, aber wer wehrt sich denn noch oder wer kann sich denn noch wehren? Technisch kann sich sowieso keiner mehr wehren. Überwachung ist, wie man schon sagte in der Runde, ist in jedem Gerät drin. Überwachung läuft nicht nur in deinem Rechner, sondern auch außerhalb deines Rechners. Also sobald die Daten irgendwo auf die Leitung gehen, werden sie überwacht. Verschlüsselung, gibt es überhaupt noch Verschlüsselung? Also bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher. Die NSA hatte 2013 Budget von 10 Milliarden Dollar.
Also ich will mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber ich glaube, die meisten Experten gehen davon aus, dass richtig angewandte Verschlüsselung verschlüsselt.
Ja, richtig angewandte Verschlüsselung, aber es wird ja alles dafür getan, dass richtig angewandte Verschlüsselung gar nicht erst stattfindet. Ich sag mal, wie war das jetzt mit Symantec und Blue Code? Das ist so ein Bereich, technisch ist der jetzt, aber Symantec hat eben Zertifikate oder RU-Zertifikate an Blue Code gegeben. Blue Code ist so eine...
Robert, Robert, das sind zu viele Details. Die Frage ist ja, wer ist du dich, wer ist du dich, Robert? Wer ist du dich gegen die Überwachung?
Kann ich nicht mehr. Ich bin zwar nicht einer von dieser Post-Privacy-Gesellschaft, aber ich glaube nicht, dass man...
Aber du könntest zum Beispiel auf die Straße gehen.
Ich könnte auf die Straße gehen, genau. Aber würde die Überwachung damit abgestellt? Die Überwachung wird nicht mehr abgestellt. Die Überwachung funktioniert einwandfrei. Die Überwachung läuft. Warum sollte ich als Gesetzgeber... Ich gebe doch nur das zu, was ich nur zugeben kann oder muss, sagen wir mal so. Warum sollte ich Überwachung abstellen? Welchen Vorteil hat für mich das?
Aber dann gehst du davon aus, dass wir ihr den Glauben an alles Demokratische aufgeben können und du in einer Welt, die du nicht mehr ändern kannst?
Im digitalen Bereich definitiv. Also ich hab mir letztens noch Zero Days angeguckt, den Film, ich weiß nicht, ob den jemand gesehen hat, über Stuxnetz. Ich gucke, ich hab damals den Film mit Robert Redford gesehen, der hieß Nekas, die Lautlosen, schon da ging es um Verschlüsselung. Schon da war mir im Grunde genommen klar, dass wir das gar nicht mehr so in der Hand haben und dass die NSA zu einem Instrument geworden ist, was man nicht mehr kontrollieren kann. Und wenn wir nicht können, aus rein budgettechnischen Gründen, wenn Deutschland nicht die Mittel hat, naja, dann wird halt im Ausland nachgefragt.
Okay, ein etwas düsterer Ausblick und vor allen Dingen also sehr hoffnungslos. Teilst du das, Anne?
Ich kann das Gefühl total gut verstehen und manchmal habe ich das auch und denke, da ist einfach nichts mehr zu machen. Und irgendwann ist mir dann aufgegangen, dass wir so eine Situation schon mal hatten. Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her und das wissen vielleicht nicht mehr alle aus eigenem Erleben, aber die Bewegung gegen Atomkraft, die hatte ganz ganz ähnliche Probleme. Atomkraft ist was, was man nicht spürt, was eine technische Entwicklung ist, der man scheinbar überhaupt nicht mehr aus dem Weg gehen konnte, weil Kohle ist irgendwann alle und Öl haben wir auch nicht. Also Atomkraft muss einfach sein. Als ich Kind war, da gab es diese Argumente tatsächlich noch, da gab es diese Auseinandersetzungen. Da hieß es ja, wollt ihr denn wieder mit Kerzen beleuchten? Es gibt einfach überhaupt keine Alternative dazu. Und die Bewegung war klein dagegen und sie hat viele Jahrzehnte gebraucht, aber es war tatsächlich möglich, dann doch sich dagegen zu wehren. Und ich glaube, wir müssen uns auf einen langen Kampf einrichten, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das hoffnungslos ist. Ich glaube, auch wir haben keine Alternative, als uns dagegen zu wehren, weil ich glaube, die Welt, wie sie wird, wenn wir in dieser totalen potenzierten Ohrwälschen-Überwachungs-Gewellschaft leben, die ist einfach nicht mehr lebenswert. Das können wir nicht hinnehmen.
Okay, darüber sprechen wir gleich. Wir müssen eine kurze Pause machen, weil jetzt wieder Nachrichtenzeit ist. Und danach machen wir mal kleine Zukunftsaussichten, vielleicht sowohl die gute als auch die schlechte Variante.
Ihr habt euch schon immer gefragt, wofür das K bei Contra K steht. Na, das steht aktuell für K. Keiner kann künftig Contra K Columbia Konzertkarten kaufen. Komplettes Kontingent. Kaufversauft. Kacke. Aber zum Glück gibt's ja noch das große rote F.
Denn Fritz hat sie für euch.
Die letzten Tickets fürs ausverkaufte Berlin-Konzert von Contra K. Freitag, 4. November. Live in der Kolumbiale. Schon komplett ausverkauft. Aber wenn ihr trotzdem noch dabei sein wollt, fritz.de slash Contra K. Die letzten Tickets fürs ausverkaufte Berlin-Konzert von Contra K.
Die Berliner SPD ist bereit, mit Linken und Grünen über eine gemeinsame Koalition zu verhandeln. Der Landesvorstand nahm am Abend eine entsprechende Empfehlung von Regierungschef Müller an. Nach den Sondierungsgesprächen hatte Müller schon gesagt, dass es viele Gemeinsamkeiten gebe. Bei der Finanz- und Energiepolitik gebe es aber noch Gesprächsbedarf. Es wäre das erste rot-rot-grüne Bündnis unter Führung der SPD in Deutschland. In Berlin-Lichtenberg soll der Leiter eines Supermarktes einen Ladendieb so schwer geschlagen haben, dass er gestorben ist. Von der Polizei heißt es, der Laden im Bahnhof Lichtenberg sei schon am Dienstag geschlossen und durchsucht worden. Gegen den Fihalleiter wurde Haftbefehl erlassen. Nach den bisherigen Ermittlungen war der Ladendieb vor zwei Wochen in dem Lebensmittelmarkt erwischt worden. Anstatt ihn der Polizei zu übergeben, soll er von dem Fihalleiter schwer misshandelt worden sein. Erst zwei Tage später habe der Mann einen Arzt aufgesucht, der ihn sofort ins Krankenhaus geschickt habe. Dort sei er dann verstorben. Die USA haben Russland damit gedroht, die Gespräche über eine Waffenruhe in Syrien abzubrechen. US-Außenminister Kerry drohte Russland damit, die Gespräche wegen der anhaltenden schweren Kämpfe um Aleppo zu beenden. Kremelsprecher Pieskov sagte aber, Russland wolle die Luftangriffe auf Aleppo fortsetzen. Inzwischen hat Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier Russland aufgefordert, sich mit den USA wenigstens auf eine vorübergehende Feuerpause zu einigen. Die täglichen Bombenangriffe müssten endlich aufhören. Schalke 04 hat in der Europa League Österreichs Meister RB Salzburg mit 3 zu 1 besiegt. Damit hat Schalke den 2. Sieg im 2. Gruppenspiel eingefahren. Fußball-Bundesligist Mainz 05 feierte seinen 1. Sieg in der Europa League. Die Mainzer gewannen in Baku beim FK Käbele mit 3 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Marzahn gerade 20 Grad und in Schöneberg noch 23, in Angermünde und Neuropin 20, in Potsdam und Frankfurt-Oder 21 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es bewölkt und zwischendurch kann es auch einzelne Schauer geben. Es kühlt noch auf bis zu 12 Grad ab. Morgen bleibt es überwiegend grau und regnerisch bei Höchstwerten um die 22 Grad. Vorsicht auf der A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden. In Höhe der Raststätte Rüblingsheide steht ein kaputtes Auto auf der Beschleunigungsspur. Zum Stadtverkehr Berlin in Mitte ist die Strahlauer Straße immer noch wegen eines Wasserrohrbruchs zwischen Mühendamm und Janowitzbrücke in Richtung Holzmarktstraße gesperrt. Bei der S-Bahn gibt es Probleme. Auch heute Nacht ist die Strecke zwischen Friedrichstraße und Charlottenburg gesperrt. Zwischen Friedrichstraße und Zoologischer Garten fahren Busse im 20-Minuten-Takt. Probleme gibt es auch bei der U-Bahnlinie 7. Bis Ende November ist die Strecke zwischen Zwickauer Damm und Rudow unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahren dort Busse. Wo ihr durchkommt, eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal Fritz.de slash Tipps.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo immer noch zu Gast sind Sebas, Ulf Bohmeyer, Anne Roth und Katharina Nocun. Hallo und guten Abend noch mal. Und wir haben jetzt eine halbe Stunde schon geredet über den NSL Untersuchungsausschuss, über den BND, über das neue BND Gesetz. Und wenn ich die letzten 90 Minuten mal zusammenfassen möchte, könnte ich sagen, es ist alles fürchterlich, weil der NSL Untersuchungsausschuss, das ist alles sehr zäh und wird auch viel geheim bleiben. Das BND-Gesetz führt im Prinzip dazu, dass der BND in Zukunft eigentlich alles überwachen darf, was es so gibt und es demonstriert niemand. Oder zu wenig. Und ich würde die letzte halbe Stunde tatsächlich gerne noch dazu nutzen, um mal zu gucken in die Zukunft, wie das werden kann. Ich würde da gerne mal in die Nachbarländer gucken. Und zwar, also was kann oder wie ist es denn, wenn so Gesetze erst mal in Kraft treten, die eine Überwachung überlauben. Und das muss man so ein bisschen vergleichen, der nicht so ganz stimmt. In Frankreich gibt es nämlich seit Ende 2015 den Ausnahmezustand und der hat zumindest abstrakt was damit zu tun. Wer von euch hat sich noch mal anguckt, was genau da alles drin steckt?
Ja, ich bin sicher kein Experte für französisches Recht. Ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch das Internet konsultiert und das hat zu dem Ergebnis geführt, dass der Etat d'urgence, der Ausnahmezustand in Frankreich, zunächst mal vom Präsidenten ausgerufen werden kann, muss dann aber durch ein Gesetz bestätigt werden und der ermöglicht eine ganze Fülle von Überwachungsmaßnahmen, aber auch anderen Einschränkungen von Bürgerrechten. Zum Beispiel können Ausgangssperren verhängt werden, die Bewegungsfreiheit kann eingeschränkt werden, Wohnungsdurchsuchungen ohne richterlichen Beschluss sind möglich oder auch Hausarreste für Menschen, also quasi Haft bei sich daheim, für Menschen, deren Aktivität als gefährlich für die Sicherheit und die öffentliche Ordnung angesehen wird. Das heißt also, das klingt auch sehr nach einem Gummi-Paragrafen und zugleich nach sehr weitreichenden Einschränkungen der klassischen bürgerlichen Freiheitsrechte.
Und es ist ja immer so mit so Sicherheitsgesetzen heißt immer, das ist ja alles gegen den Terror und dass man das auch für andere Sachen verwenden kann. Gibt es eine konkrete Geschichte Katharina?
Ja genau, und zwar gab es einen Global March on Climate, der fand in ganz Europa in unterschiedlichen Städten am selben Tag statt und ich war da näher dran, weil ein Kollege von mir so in der Organisation in Berlin mitgemischt hat. Und eigentlich war so ein Event in Paris geplant, was auch Sinn macht, da die Konferenz, wo über das Klima debattiert wurde, auch in Paris stattfand. Diese Demonstration wurde aber verboten, auch mit Hilfe dieser Notstandsgesetze. Und Aktivisten, die in dem Umfeld tätig waren oder die dafür mobilisiert haben, haben eben diese Ausgangssperren bekommen. Das heißt, Leute, die ganz bestimmt nichts mit Terrorismus zu tun haben, thematisch was vollkommen anderes, die einfach nur friedlich demonstrieren wollten, die konnten es dann nicht. Was ich aber ganz schön fand, ist, dass es trotzdem dann einen Protest gab. Und zwar haben die Veranstalter aus Protestern ganz viele Schuhe aufgestellt von Leuten, die zu der Demo gekommen wären auf dem Platz. Das heißt, es sind einfach Leute vorbeigekommen, haben ihre Schuhe dort abgestellt, dann quasi nach der Demo wieder abgeholt. Und um klarzumachen, das geht so nicht.
Aber ich würde persönlich sagen wollen, dass das Gesetz missbraucht worden ist. Weil gegen Klimawandel ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Terror. Und Ausnahmezustand hat ja auch so was temporäres eigentlich. Aber das gibt es jetzt seit ein paar Monaten und es ist auch sozusagen nicht so abzusehen, wann das wieder eingestellt wird. Das finde ich auch spannend. Und das zeigt es halt sehr schön, dass so eine Gesetze, die dem Staat viel Macht geben, dann auch gekommen sind, um zu bleiben. Das ist zumindest so mein Eindruck.
Also das Gesetz ist ja eingesetzt worden im November 2015 und erst mal bis Januar 2017 beschränkt in Frankreich. Nur die Frage, die sich stellen wird, wird man das Gesetz wieder zurücknehmen oder wird man es verlängern? Weil ich möchte ja auch niemand die Verantwortung übernehmen, wenn dann etwas passiert, wenn das Gesetz zurückgenommen worden ist in seiner jetzigen Form. Na ja, man hat ja jetzt alle Möglichkeiten, um gegen den Terror anzugehen und sich dagegen zu schützen. Und wenn man jetzt dieses Mittel, was man in Kraft gesetzt hat, wieder zurücknimmt und dann etwas passiert, muss man da natürlich auch die politischen Konsequenzen ziehen. Und die möchte aktuell niemand tragen.
Das heißt, Überwachungsgesetze werden nicht zurückgenommen, weil kein Politiker das Gesicht verlieren will?
Na, weil auch vielleicht nicht genügend Widerstand aus der Bevölkerung kommt.
Also bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung kann man ja ganz konkret sagen, dass Sigmar Gabriel offen kommuniziert hat, er möchte dieses Gesetz durchbringen, obwohl der Justizminister Heiko Maas ja auch eigentlich dagegen war oder zumindest öffentlich gesagt hat, er möchte das auch nach den Anschlägen in Paris nicht durchdrücken, weil er eben gesagt hat, na ja, wenn ein Terroranschlag hier in Deutschland stattfinden sollte, dann wird sofort der Finger auf die SPD fallen. Warum habt ihr das denn nicht gemacht? Weil mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung kann ja bekanntlich alles verhindert werden, was ja auch so nicht stimmt.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn ich das nochmal kurz erläutern würde.
Das war ironisch gemeint. Es ist halt immer so die Standardargumentation, ja, mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten wir das verhindern können, obwohl wir ja ganz klar sehen, dass beispielsweise die Attentate in Paris nicht mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung verhindert werden konnten. Und gerade, wenn ich weiß, dass so ein Gesetz in Kraft tritt, oder in Kraft ist in einem Land, das eben speichern, mit wem ich wann telefoniere, wäre ich ja dumm, sag ich mal, mein eigenes Handy zu nutzen, um darüber einen eventuellen Anschlag zu planen.
Und deswegen müssen wir Verschlüsselung verbieten und beim Handykauf immer den Personalausweis vorlegen lassen.
Ja, also diese Mehr von der totalen Sicherheit ist aus meiner Sicht eben eine ganz fatale. Aus meiner Sicht müssen wir eben irgendwo akzeptieren, dass es eine totale Sicherheit nicht gibt. Ich habe eben, also ich habe vor einigen Monaten war ich in einer Podiumsdiskussion, da hat jemand etwas ganz Kluges aus dem Publikum gesagt. Und zwar hatte der sich angeschaut, wie viele Leute eigentlich pro Jahr von aus dem Fenster geschmissenen Fernsehern tödlich verletzt werden. Und das sind gar nicht so wenige. Und wenn wir uns einfach anschauen, es gibt immer ein Risiko und wir werden es nicht total verhindern können. Wenn wir aber versuchen, das Risiko auf Null zu drücken, a. werden wir es nicht schaffen und b. landen wir dann einfach in einem totalitären Start. Und dann, würde ich sagen, ist der größte Anschlag gegen die Demokratie geglückt. Dann haben wir nämlich unsere freiheitlichen Werte von ganz alleine aufgegeben.
Es gibt tatsächlich aber Leute, die denken, Überwachung hat auch was Gutes. Und einer davon hat angerufen, nämlich der Nils aus Lichterfeld. Hallo und guten Abend. Was genau soll denn Überwachung Gutes haben?
Für mich, also ich rede jetzt mal ausschließlich über die Geheimdienste und nicht über WhatsApp, Facebook, Google, Microsoft und Co. Ich denke, wenn mehr publik gemacht werden würde, welche Vorteile oder Ermittlungsergebnisse auch eine Überwachung hat, dann wäre ein Großteil der Bevölkerung auch bereit, gewisse Daten preiszugeben.
Aber was für konkrete Vorteile meinst du denn?
Ich meine jetzt nicht nur Terrorismus, ob links oder rechts, das ist völlig egal, sondern einfach Verbrechen aufgedeckt werden anhand von Überwachung.
Ja, aber welche Verbrechen sind das? Also ich habe jetzt...
Eben, das wissen wir ja nicht.
Ach warte, du behauptest also sagen, eigentlich hilft Überwachung schon gegen Verbrechensaufklärung, und das wird uns aber nicht gesagt. Das halte ich also mit Verlauf sehr weit hergeholt.
Also Teile der Antwort würden uns verunsichern.
Also ganz kurz, also A gibt es sozusagen, was die Vorwärtssatenspeicherung angeht, immer wieder Untersuchungen in Ländern, wo es die Vorwärtssatenspeicherung gibt, dass das nichts hilft. Und B, also um die... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das nachvollziehen sollte, weil die Politik, der wird ja immer gesagt, beweist doch mal bitte, dass diese ganze Überwachung funktioniert. Und dann sagt sie, ja tut sie ja, wir würden es euch auch konkret zeigen, aber das geht halt nicht so genau. Aus welcher Motivation sollte denn das verschwiegen werden?
Bei für mich einfachen Geheimdienst, ob das der BND ist oder die NSA oder in anderen Ländern XYZ, wir wissen auf der einen Seite nicht wirklich, was sie tun, oder wir vermuten und unterstellen einfach mal, sie tun alles, nur nichts Gutes. Es gibt immer zwei Seiten, also ich glaube, es gibt einige Fälle, die Spitze des Eisberges. Wir erfahren doch nicht alles, was wirklich passiert.
Nils, um das abzukürzen und sagen, du glaubst, das versuche ich gerade noch mal zu fragen, du glaubst also, durch Überwachung werden Verbrechen aufgeklärt und deswegen findest du Überwachung gut?
Das heißt nicht, dass ich Überwachung gut finde, aber mir wird das alles ein bisschen zu negativ dargestellt. Klar kann man auf der einen Seite sagen, wer nichts zu verbergen hat, der soll sich nicht aufregen. Ich bin in so einer Generation, 78, ich wäre 40. Ja, ich mach's.
Ich versuche das noch mal genauer zu vergründen. Also das finde ich jetzt einen natürlich unspannenden Punkt, weil wie kann man denn als Überwachungsgegner dagegen argumentieren, wenn jemand sagt, na ja, aber uns wird ja sozusagen verheimlicht, was das für gute Seiten hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man da anfangen soll.
Naja, also da kann ich vielleicht mal einwerfen als Argument. Bei ganz konkreten Anschlägen in Brüssel beispielsweise oder auch in Frankreich ist ja im Nachhinein rausgekommen, dass der Geheimdienst tatsächlich Information hatte, weil man sich allerdings so auf Massenüberwachungsinstrumente konzentriert hat, hat man quasi die Nadel im Heuhoffen nicht mehr gefunden.
Was Dieter sagt, es gibt...
Das ist aus meiner Sicht eben die Unterscheidung, die man treffen muss. Also zielgerichtete Ermittlungen, denke ich, klar, sollte man auf jeden Fall tun. Und ich denke, sie ist auch... Ich weiß, dass sie tatsächlich effektiver ist als Massenüberwachung, die erst mal alle Bürger einschließt. Und diese Unterscheidung an Effektivität, die wird in der Politik aus meiner Sicht gar nicht gerade diskutiert. Und das ist der Fehler.
Das ist, glaube ich, aber eine kategoriale Unterscheidung, die ganz wichtig ist. Denn ich würde zum Beispiel niemand sagen, wir brauchen überhaupt gar keine Überwachung, um mal ein Beispiel zu bilden. Wenn man jetzt tatsächlich jemanden im Verdacht hat, er könnte einen anderen Menschen umgebracht haben. Und deswegen werden gegen ihn strafrechtliche Ermittlungen geführt. Und der hat eine Freundin. Und man hofft halt einfach, dass er möglicherweise am Telefon irgendwas Belastendes sagt. Warum soll man dann nicht dessen Handy zum Beispiel überwachen? Das ist eine zielgerichtete Überwachung aufgrund eines bestimmten Tatverdachts. Ich persönlich rechtsstaatlich überhaupt kein Problem mit. Das sollten wir tun. Das eigentliche Problem ist eben genau dieses Stichwort Massenüberwachung, der gerade kein Verdacht zugrunde liegt, wo einfach jeder im Prinzip ins Raster fallen kann. Und da in diese Kategorie fällt eben die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo die Verkehrsdaten von allen Menschen gespeichert werden oder eben die Internetüberwachung des BND, die ja eben gerade keine bestimmten Verdächtigen ins Ziel, äh ins Visier nimmt, sondern einfach jedermann. Und wie Katja gerade schon gesagt hat, ist das große Problem bei der Massenüberwachung, eben die berühmte Nadel in diesem gigantischen Heuhaufen zu finden. Und das scheint immer weniger zu gelingen. Sascha Lobo hat das am Beispiel der Attentäter von Paris mal im Spiegel genauer analysiert. Von denen waren einige sogar mit Haftbefehl gesucht. Andere standen zumindest auf Beobachtungslisten der Polizei. Es fehlte nicht an irgendwie Daten. Also es war einfach, Daten waren da. Es fehlte an Menschen, die die auswerten. Mit anderen Worten, wenn man wirklich sich um Sicherheit Gedanken macht, dann sollte man, wie sie gerade schon sagte, wegkommen von dieser Massenüberwachung, die im Wesentlichen eine Illusion von Sicherheit schafft. Man muss sich Gedanken machen, wo liegen denn die wirklichen Probleme, weswegen Ermittlungsbehörden im konkreten Fall versagt haben. Leider, gerade in Frankreich und Belgien gibt es ja diese Fälle des Versagens in Deutschland bislang jedenfalls deutlich weniger. Aber um auf diesen Anrufer zurückzukommen, wenn tatsächlich Attentate aufgrund von Geheimdienstinformationen verhindert werden konnten, dann scheint mir das sehr offensiv kommuniziert zu werden. Mir fällt allerdings nur ein Beispiel ein, das waren die sogenannten Sauerland-Bomber. Das waren ja Menschen, die in einer Garage chemische Stoffe gesammelt haben, mit denen sie dann möglicherweise Bomben bauen wollten. Und da wurde relativ offensiv kommuniziert. Ob das stimmt, weiß man nicht. Dass da ein Tipp eines ausländischen Geheimdienstes ausschlaggebend war. Ob das tatsächlich stimmt, wissen wir nicht. Aber das ist so der einzige Fall, den ich persönlich jedenfalls gerade vor Augen habe. Es mag ein paar andere geben. Aber es stimmt, glaube ich, nicht, dass solche Fahndungserfolge aufgrund von Geheimdienstinformationen unter der Decke gehalten werden. Ganz im Gegenteil. Wenn es denn tatsächlich mal Erfolge gibt, dann wird das sehr offensiv kommuniziert.
Teilweise werden auch versucht, ergebliche Erfolge zu kommunizieren, die gar keine waren. Wenn ich mich jetzt an das Jahr 2013 erinnere, direkt nach den Snowden-Enthüllungen stand ja der BND unter unglaublichen Druck, dass er das irgendwie vermittelt und erklärt. Und da wurde eine Pressekonferenz gegeben, da wurde gesagt, wir haben massenhaft Terroranschläge mithilfe dieser Daten der NSA in Deutschland verhindern können. Und in den darauffolgenden Monaten gab es eben eine größere Diskussion. Da wurde wieder nachgefragt, naja nennen sie das doch mal jetzt die konkreten Beispiele. Und da ist nichts von übergeblieben. Das heißt, es gab gar keine nachweisbaren Effekte, positiven Effekte dieser Überwachung. Was eben übrig geblieben ist, ist das, was der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss aufgeklärt hat, eben diese ganzen negativen Beispiele, dass massenweise Journalisten, NGOs, EU-Abgeordnete teilweise da ins Raster gefallen sind.
Ich meine, wenn man genau hinguckt, dann stellt man fest, die Sauerlandgruppe und die geplanten Attentate von denen, das ist das Beispiel, was von den Diensten permanent hochgehalten wird. Wenn es heißt, was waren denn die Erfolge aktuell, die Sauerlandgruppe und dann noch irgendwie diese Messerstecherin aus Hannover, Islamistin, junge Frau, ganz dramatisch. Das sind die beiden Beispiele, die du permanent präsentiert kriegst und andere gibt es nicht. Ich würde gerne noch widersprechen wollen zu dieser Geschichte, dass es bisher glücklicherweise keine Fälle gegeben hat, hier in Deutschland, wo Geheimdienste versagt haben, vielleicht nicht im Bereich große Terroranschläge, aber wenn wir jetzt mal kurz den Blick auf den Verfassungsschutz und auf den NSU lenken, würde ich sagen, da ist sehr großflächig versagt worden. Und selbst der Verfassungsschutz ist im Nachhinein noch mal wieder kräftig aufgerüstet worden, auch eher im Bereich Internetüberwachung und Massenüberwachung. Und das geht einfach total in die falsche Richtung. Wenn man dann als nächstes, und das gehört zu dem, was ich momentan viel mache, den Politikern und den Diensten genau zuhört, dann sagen die natürlich auf jeden Fall auch, na das, was wir machen hier, ist keine Massenüberwachung, das hörst du in den USA ganz genauso. Wir machen hier nur gezielte Überwachung. Ganz gezielt suchen wir nur nach Terroristen und dann noch ein bisschen nach organisierter Kriminalität und noch ein bisschen nach Waffenhandel. Aber das ist ganz gezielt und das ist keine Massenüberwachung. Aber dafür benutzen sie dann eben Millionen und Milliarden von Selektoren und sammeln Massen von Daten, versuchen uns aber zu verkaufen, dass das diese ungediebte Massenüberwachung vielleicht doch irgendwie nicht wäre.
Aber was ich mich zu sagen am Ende frage ist, es wird ja sozusagen nicht nur heute hier wurde das noch mal ganz klar dargelegt, sondern das kann man sich ja auch anlesen, wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Also man kommt sozusagen nicht dran vorbei, dass Überwachung was Schlechtes ist, was Auswirkungen auf eine Gesellschaft hat, was auch Auswirkungen auf den Einzelnen haben kann. Was ich mich da frage ist, warum wird denn das trotzdem immer vorgeschlagen? Das kann ich mir bei BND konkret vorstellen. Das ist eine Behörde, die hat auch ein Budget, die hat auch Leute, die muss ihren Selbstzweck erhalten. Das ist ein Selbstwert, die nicht, wenn man sagt, was wir machen, das ist ganz toll, wir brauchen auch mehr Geld und dann ist Überwachung so super. Aber Politik zum Beispiel.
Das haben wir vorhin schon mal, diese Frage, warum machen die Politiker das alles mit? Und da kann man sich innen Politiker lang und breit angucken. Interessant ist ja auch immer, in dem Moment, wo die im Amt sind, sind die total scharfe Hunde. Und im Moment, wo sie dann nicht mehr im Amt sind, also nehmen wir zum Beispiel mal Gerd Baum, war früher Innenminister in Deutschland, ist jetzt ein wirklich engagierter Überwachungskritiker und da ist er nicht der einzige. Es gibt keine wirklich schlüssige Erklärung dafür, was ich ganz interessant fand, um vielleicht noch mal den Blick auch auf Snowden und die Enthüllungen zu lenken. Da gibt es ja ganz klare Hinweise dafür, dass die Geheimdienste, und jetzt kann man mir sagen, das ist irgendwie spinne, aber steht so in den Unterlagen, kann man nachlesen. Die sammeln ja aber auch Überwachungsergebnisse über eben genau die Politiker, um die gegebenenfalls damit erpressen zu können, damit die dann die Entscheidungen so treffen, wie die Dienste das wollen. Dazu gibt es für Deutschland bisher keinerlei Belege, jedenfalls sind mir keine bekannt. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Politiker, die sich letzten Endes oft fachlich vielleicht den Diensten auch unterlegen fühlen, erstens die Verantwortung nicht übernehmen wollen, wenn denn doch mal was passiert. Das heißt, wenn man ihnen genügend ausführlich schildert, wie schrecklich die Gefahren sind, dann ist das schon mal ein passendes Argument. Und wenn zweitens ihnen dann noch gesagt wird, pass auf, wenn du nicht genauso entscheidest, wie ich das gerne hätte, dann packe ich hier doch mal zum Beispiel das Strafverfahren wegen Körperverletzung auf den Tisch, was hier im Moment noch in einem Archiv vor sich hin schimmelt, was du gerne nicht in der Öffentlichkeit haben willst. Das wäre sozusagen nur ein Beispiel. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es davon noch mehr gibt. Ich glaube, die Dienste, die haben faktisch keine Kontrolle. Und die wollen auch nicht kontrolliert werden. Das heißt, die versuchen, sich die Politik auch vom Leib zu halten. Und die Politik ist oft auch ganz froh, wenn sie es nicht so genau weiß, wenn sie die Verantwortung nicht übernehmen muss. Das ist eine Win-Win-Situation für beide. Und die Demokratie fällt aber leider dabei hinten runter.
Und um noch mal auf die Struktur der Politik zu kommen, bei Überwachungsgesetzen ist ja auch die Argumentation, dass das nur vorübergehend. Die Sicherheitslage ist jetzt angespannt. Wir müssen jetzt was tun. Hinterher packen wir das alles wieder weg. Das Problem ist aber, es gibt keinen gesetzlichen Sicherheitsmechanismus, der quasi vorschreibt, nach einem Jahr oder nach zwei Jahren muss jetzt untersucht werden, wie der Anrufer auch eben angeregt hat. Also es muss dann offensiv kommuniziert werden, was sind die Erfolge, aber auch natürlich, was sind die Misserfolge, beispielsweise wo wurde offensichtlich Missbrauch betrieben. Und auf dieser Basis müssen dann die Politiker, sage ich mal, argumentieren, warum sie dieses Gesetz entweder weiter fortlaufen lassen wollen oder warum das eben eingesammelt oder angepasst werden muss. Und tatsächlich gab es mal so einen Prozess bei der europäischen Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. 2010 gab es eine Re-Evaluation der EU-Richtlinie. Da bin ich dann nach Brüssel gefahren mit einigen Aktivisten-Kollegen von AK Vorrat. Und wir haben monatelang vorher ein Shadow-Paper, also so ein Shadow-Report geschrieben, also ein Dokument, wo ganz viele unterschiedliche Fälle aus allen EU-Mitgliedsstaaten aufgelistet wurde, wo die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ganz konkret missbraucht wurde, um beispielsweise Journalisten zu überwachen. Oder wo beispielsweise die Polizistin wegen irgendeiner Beziehung dann mal in der Datenbank privat nachgeguckt hat. Und wir haben das dann eingereicht und sind dann zu der Sitzung gefahren. Und dann hat der Vertreter der Kommission gesagt, ja, Missbrauchsfälle sind uns nicht bekannt. Und neben mir die Vertreterin aus Polen hat ihre Hand gehoben, war total sauer, meinte so wie. Wir haben doch das Dokument eingereicht. Und er meinte, na ja, wir haben die Vertreter der EU-Mitgliedstaaten, die Regierung gefragt, ist Missbrauch bekannt? Und sie haben gesagt nein. Und da habe ich an der Stelle wirklich eine Frust geschoben. Ich war kurz davor hinzuschmeißen, mich nicht mehr zu engagieren. Und ich bin der Meinung, man muss einfach auch Bürgerrechtsorganisationen stärker einbinden und auch stärker hören, wenn es um Bedenken geht. Im Vorfeld und nicht im Nachhinein. Dann müssen wir auch nicht auf die Straße gehen.
Es bleibt noch einiges zu tun. Die Sendung ist leider gleich vorbei. Ich würde deswegen etwas in weiser Voraussicht machen, weil als wir letztes Jahr sozusagen über das Thema gesprochen haben, wussten wir nicht, dass wir uns dieses Jahr auch nochmal drüber unterhalten werden und sich gar nicht so viel geändert hat. Ich würde aber vermuten, nächstes Jahr haben wir wieder Gelegenheit. Und deswegen jetzt noch mal der Reihe nach die Frage an euch, worüber reden wir in einem Jahr?
Über das verabschiedete und in Kraft getretene BND-Gesetz, das vom Verfassungsschutz, vom Verfassungsgericht kassiert wurde. Ich glaube, das wird bis nächstes Jahr nicht vom Verfassungsgericht kassiert werden, sondern das wird noch zwei Jahre dauern, bis das im Gesetz kassiert wird.
Alles klar.
Ulf?
Ich möchte eine Hoffnung äußern. Im nächsten Jahr, um diese Zeit, befinden wir uns entweder gerade noch im Bundestagswahlkampf, der genaue Termin steht noch nicht fest, oder? Oder steht schon fest? Jedenfalls ist es die Zeit der Bundestagswahl. Ich hoffe, dass wir im Vorfeld dieser Wahl intensiver darüber diskutieren, welche Rolle der Schutz von Privatsphäre und der Schutz vor Überwachung im politischen System spielen. Und dass wir auch ganz gezielt dann die Bewerber und politische Ämter fragen, wie hältst du es mit der Privatsphäre?
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wann die Wahl ist, aber ich glaube, Ende September wird sie dann gewesen sein. Das heißt, wir werden uns langsam warmlaufen für den nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss.
Ich sitze ja auch im Beirat des Whistleblower-Netzwerks. Deshalb hoffe ich stark darauf, dass wir uns im nächsten Jahr über das quasi deutsche Pendant zu Edward Snowden unterhalten werden. Den BND-Mitarbeiter, der nochmal ganz andere Sachen ausgepackt hat, als Vorarbeit für den nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss.
Alles klar, darf ich auch gerne dabei. Also liebe BND-Mitarbeiter, wenn ihr diese Sendung gehört habt, wisst ihr jetzt, an wen ihr euch wenden könnt. Liebe Gäste, die hier wart, vielen Dank für die erhellenden und wenn manchmal auch ein bisschen frustrierenden Erkenntnisse und Erlebnisse aus der Diskussion um Überwachung. Ich habe noch eine kurze Sache zu sagen und zwar, falls ihr euch dafür interessiert, was ganz junge Menschen mit der Technik neu machen, könnt ihr am 16. Oktober zur Jugendhackt-Abschlussveranstaltung kommen. Diese in der Volksbühne ist also richtig viel Platz, da könnt ihr alle kommen. Und ansonsten bleibt noch zu sagen, nach uns kommt Flo Heiler, wird euch mit Gitarrenmusik bewerfen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, ihr könnt das gerne als Podcast hören und macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst sie nicht überwachen.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network, Bjatch!